WE WILL.
COME TO ORDER AND WE WILL BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET.
I THIS IS THE FIRST HEARING OF
BILLS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
OF THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
AND I AM PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE HAVE BACK WITH US.
A TECHNICAL.
A WELCOME BACK.
AS A PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
I LIKE EVERYONE TO PLEASE NOTE
THAT ARE GENERAL GUIDELINES FOR
BILLS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO ALLOW TESTIMONY OF TWO
WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH.
AND THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
I KNOW WE CAN DO IT SINCE WE.
DON'T REALLY HAVE A.
QUORUM YET.
ALRIGHT SO.
WE WILL THEN BEGIN WITH THE
FIRST BILL.
AND THAT IS.
A. B. EIGHTEEN OH THREE.
CHOI FEEL LIKE TO COME UP.
DO THIS ONCE.
YOU NEED TO DO.
WELCOME HISTORY CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON AND THE
MEMBERS ARE GOOD TO BE BACK ON
AND I USE JUST SIT THAT THE BIAS
WITH YOU BUT NOW.
A I AM PRESENTING.
COUPLE BILLS TODAY FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION FIRST ONE IS SAW
A. B. EIGHTEEN OR THREE.
DOT WOULD REQUIRE YOUR
UNIVERSITY IS SET TO OFFER.
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CAREER SAID
SERVICES TO UP TO FIVE YEARS.
AFTER YEARS. OF STUDENTS A
GRADUATE OF FROM DO
INSTITUTIONS.
A RECENT.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A GALLUP
POLL FOUND THAT THE ORKNEYS
SIXTY PERCENT OF UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS I HAVE EVER VISITED.
A COLLEGE CAREER CENTER WHITE
USED DOT ANNUAL VIDEO CENTERS
SELL ONLINE RESOURCES.
ADDITIONALLY OUT THE POOR PHONE
DATA LAST AND TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF STUDENTS ARE
UTILIZE DOT PRINT COLLEGE
SERVICES SOUND LIKE A SKILL
ASSESSMENTS.
AND MOCK INTERVIEWS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE
SERVICES TAUGHT TYPICALLY ARE
FREE FOR CURRENT STUDENTS.
WHILE THESE.
UNDER IT DIES A SON NOW COULD BE
EXPLAINED UP ID UP BC SCHEDULE.
ARE OF A STUDENT ARE TRYING TO.
PAST LEO CLASSES.
ONLY EIGHTEEN PERCENT OF OUR
STUDENTS VISIT THERE CARILLO
CENTER AS SO NEW GRADUATES.
THIS.
UNDER UTILIZED H. ON BY RECENT
GRADUATE SITE IS SOUGHT
ESPECIALLY ALARMING.
OF THE THIRTY TWO CSU AND THE UC
CAMPUSES BEST SERVER
UNDERGRADUATES.
ONLY TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES SO
OFFERED HIS SERVICES TO RECENT
ALUMNI AT NO CHARGE.
HOWEVER.
THAT THE. PERIOD DAVA
ELIGIBILITY OFTEN AND SO WITHIN
SIX MONTHS.
AFTER WHICH A STUDENT IS TO
REQUIRE THE TO PAY.
BEVERAGES CHARGE OVER ANYWAY NO
FIFTY DOLLARS UP TO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS SO YEAR TOWARD
ACCESS THOSE SAME SERVICES OF A
ALREADY PAID.
PAID FOR WITH THEO TUITION.
TO COMPOUND THIS ARE INFORMATION
THOSE STUDENTS ARE.
WHO TEND TO UTILIZE OF THESE
SERVICES?
THE MORE STOCK ROB BLACK A AND
THE HISPANIC STUDENTS AS WELL AS
A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
AND DOT NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS
SO WHO ARE LEAST LIKELY AFFORD
TO PAY THESE FEES.
COLLEAGUES TO HER.
BY ENACTING AB I EIGHTEEN OR
THREE. WE PROVIDE THE ON
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP A RECENT
GRADUATES.
BUT PAYING EMPLOYMENT
AND.
CONTRIBUTE.
TO OUR SOCIETY I. RESPECTIVELY
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING.
AFTERNOON A BRIGHT OF BIGGER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSION WE DO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
GIVE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE OF A ABOUT
THIS BILL. WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION YET DOES BUT
AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. WE DO HAVE A FEW I CAN
CONCERNED ABOUT WORK WORKLOAD
AND FUNDING ISSUES.
AND HOW THIS COULD AFFECT
PRIORITIES SUCH AS I'M IMPROVING
ACCESS TO THE SEA IF YOU IN OUR
GRADUATION. INITIATIVE ON THAT
WERE ALSO A LITTLE BIT CAN
CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER PER
PROVIDING STE.
SERVICES
TO STUDENTS FOR FOR THIS LONG
COULD IMPACT SERVICES TO CURRENT
STUDENTS.
ON THAT WE WILL BE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
ERICA REMAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE ALSO DO NOT HAVE
A POSITION AT THIS TIME. BUT DO
YOU HAVE CONCERNS THAT TO THE
EXTENT THAT INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY DOING THIS AS TWITCH
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTIONS THAT
ARE NOT PUBLICLY FUNDED. THIS
COULD CREATE COST PRESSURES AND
TAKE AWAY FROM OTHER PRIORITIES
OF THE INSTITUTIONS.
SO I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY TWEENER ANYBODY AND IN
BETWEEN SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
AND COME FORWARD.
ANY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT HEARING NONE.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NO WE DON'T HAVE.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
NOPE.
OKAY CHAIR IF I CANNOT COMMENT
THOUGH ON THE.
SOME CONCERN DOT COM IS SET
THAT I HEAR.
IT IS SO VERY.
UNLIKELY THAT THE CURRENT
OPERATION OF.
CARILLO CENTERS SO WOULD BE.
LA OVERWHELMED BY EXTENDING
THIS PERIOD THAT BECAUSE AS YOU
AS I MENTIONED THAT UP.
ADULT RATIO OF AQUARIUS IT SENT
TO YOU SEE YOU CELEBRATE YOU LOW
IS TO SIMPLY PROVIDING THE
FLEXIBILITY RATHER THAN JUST A
LIMITING. YOU KNOW THREE MONTHS
OR SIX MONTHS US SO I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE PEAK
ADDITIONAL ACOSTA AND THE OR SO
WE ARE NOT MANDATING. ANY ARE
NOW UNIVERSITIES OR COLLEGES TO
WITHOUT THE KOREA CENTER
CURRENTLY TO HAVE IT.
WHEN THEY HAVE OF SUCH SERVICES.
UP TO BE A FLEXIBLE.
MISS QUIRK SILVA QUESTION
COMMENT I WAS GONNA MAKE A
COMMENT I DO I DO LIKE THIS BILL
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE SEEN THAT. ON.
NOT ONLY FOR MY OWN A. CHILDREN
THAT AT ALL GRADUATED RECENTLY
IS THAT SOME OF THE STUDENTS AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED DON'T
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE CAREER
CENTER. HOT DURING THEIR FOUR
YEARS BUT ONCE THEY ARE ACTUALLY
LOOKING FOR A JOB OR NEEDING
OUGHT TO REALLY FINALIZE WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PRESENT FORWARD
TO THE. COMMUNITY IN THE
WORKPLACE SOMETIMES THEY DO JUST
WANT THAT EXTRICITY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI SAYS THAT
THERE'S THIS COULD BE A RUN ON
CAREER PLACEMENTS AND PEOPLE CAN
BE STANDING OUTSIDE SO.
AYE I THINK WE WANT TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS EVEN
AFTER THEY GRADUATE.
THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IF NOT WE WILL THEN GO ON TO
YEARS SECOND BILL DOCTOR CHOI.
OKAY.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON NOT MY
SECOND BILL AND ASIDE EIGHT BE
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE THIS ONE HAS
TO DO. A SPECIFIC FOKKER'S SAW
OF CONCERN AS HOW CUANDO. A
COLLEGE OR FOR THE MEDIA PLANS.
AB NINETEEN SIXTY ONE. INCREASES
THE FREEDOM OF THE TORIES FOR
STUDENTS.
BY PREVENTING COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO FROM. REQUIRING
THE PURCHASE OF A MID PLANS.
AS A CONDITION OF OUR LIVING IN
CAMPUS UP PROVIDED A HOSTING.
ADDITIONALLY UNIVERSITIES SAW A
WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED TO
SEPARATE.
COST OF A CAMPUS PROVIDED A
MEDIA PLANS.
AND THE HOUSING PLAN SO ON THEIR
CAMPERS WEBSITES.
AND THE LITERATURE TO INCREASE
OUR FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY.
THIS YEAR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF.
CALIFORNIA IRVINE.
THE CURRENT COST OF OUR ROOM AND
BOARD.
.
YOU KNOW NOW ONE CAMPUS OF OUR
TRIP OCCUPANCY ROOM.
OUT WITH A MEAL PLAN PORTER SAID
NEARLY THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
SOME UNIVERSITIES HOSTED REQUIRE
FRESHMEN AND THE TRANSFER OF
STUDENTS HAVE TO PURCHASE A
MINUTE PLANS TO.
EVEN A FATHER HOUSING UNITS ARE.
THAT THEY LIVE IN NOW OFFER
POKING AMENITIES.
OVER THE PAST DECADE. AVERAGE
ABOARD THE.
THAT IS SOUGHT TWENTY.
MIA SUPPORT WEEK GOV AT THE FOUR
YEAR COLLEGES TO HAS A REASON
FORTY SIX UP PERCENT.
TWO FOUR THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
TWO DOLLARS TO FOUR.
ARE THAT WAS SO A LITTLE BIT DOT
ORG DATA TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
TO TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR EDUCATION STATISTICS.
THIS REQUIREMENT.
NOT TO PURCHASE A MEAL PLAN
ELIMINATES A STUDENT TORIES. IN
A
DETERMINING WHAT WOULD BE MORE
ECONOMICAL FOR DO WELLBEING.
BY ENACTING A BE NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE WE ENSURE CHOI EACH SET AND
THE FLEXIBILITY FOR STUDENTS
AND.
THEIR PARENTS.
THE BETTER A FULL.
A COTTAGE.
I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK WILL YOUR AYE VOTE AS WELL.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WINNERS ARE AYE THAT'S GOOD
WINNERS AND NOT SEEN ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
ALEX GRAVES THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WE DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
BILL.
OUT WE HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THE
FIRST COMPONENT REGARDING DIS
AGGREGATING THE INFORMATION FOR
OUR MEAL PLANS VERSUS HOUSING
THAT WE MOST NOT ALL OUR
CAMPUSES ARE YOU DO THAT.
REGARDING THE PROVISION ON THE
MEAL PLANS I JUST NOT A FEW
THINGS ARE THERE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF UNIVERSITY OPERATED HOUSING
ARE FROM YOUR KIND OF
TRADITIONAL DORMITORY TO
UNIVERSE ARE EXCUSE ME. TOO I
YOUR APARTMENT STYLE HOUSING
WHERE YOU HAVE NO FULL KITCHENS
IN THE RESIDENTS. AND OUT TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE THE REQUIREMENT AROUND
MEAL PLANS FOR RESIDENCY ONLY
APPLIES TO THOSE UNITS WHICH DO
NOT HAVE A KITCHEN IN THE UNIT.
.
AND I WOULD THINK I WOULD SAY
THAT OUR CONCERNS NAMELY FOCUSED
ON A FEW THINGS FIRST OUT.
CONTRACTUALLY WE DO HAVE
EXISTING CONTRACTS AND WE DO.
AND HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THIS MIGHT IMPACT SOME OF OUR
EXISTING CONTRACTS AS WELL AS
OUR.
ABILITY NEGOTIATE FUTURE
CONTRACTS AT BEST PRICES.
AT IT IN TERMS OF STUDENT SAFETY
I OBVIOUSLY IN OUR DORMITORIES
WE DON'T ALLOW HOT PLATES OR
TOASTER OVENS.
DUE TO FIRE SAFETY CONCERNS AND
LASTLY I ON STUDENT CHOICE I WE
WE ARE CANCERS PROVIDE A RANGE
OF MEAL PLANS.
A DIFFERENT PRICE POINTS FOR
STUDENTS TO CHOOSE FROM AND WE
ARE ABLE TO OFFER THOSE.
STUDENTS QUITE NUTRITIOUS MEALS
AT IN SOME INSTANCES I ON THE
COME ARE FULL SCALE MEAL PLANS
UNDER FIVE DOLLARS A MEAL FOR
UNLIMITED SWIPES ALL YOU CAN EAT
WHILE YOU'RE THERE. SO CAN WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
CONTENT WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
IN CONVERSATIONS ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE TO DO
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL.
WHOEVER YOU WANTED ARTICULATE IF
YOU CONCERNS WE ARE SEVERAL THE
CAMPUSES LISTED URINALYSIS THAT
DO NOTS OF BREAKOUT OR TOWARDS
THIS AGGREGATE. THE DATA WITH
RESPECT TO MEAL PLANS AND AND.
ROOM COSTS AND SO EXTENT THIS
BILL WERE TO MOVE FORWARD WOULD
REPLY REQUIRE UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
WE CAN DO THAT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE CURRENTLY DO AND.
WITH REGARD TO.
WHAT THOSE COSTS ARE IT'S
IMPORTANT POINT OUT THAT THERE'S
NOT JUST ROOM AND BOARD AS A
FUNCTION OF THAT OF THAT?
CALCULATION IT ALSO INCLUDES.
OTHER SERVICES ARE PROVIDED IN
THE IN THE RESIDENTIAL SETTING
SUCH AS.
WIRELESS TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
COMPUTING LABS PRINTING SERVICES
AND OTHER SERVICES THAT WE OFFER
WITHIN OUR DORMITORIES AND SO.
THAT'S FIRST AND FOREMOST ON THE
ON THE MAIN POINT WHETHER NOT
THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE RUDE.
DISINCLINED TO REQUIRE THE
SERVICES OF THE MEAL PLAN
SERVICES WE WOULD ARGUE THAT.
GIVEN THE.
ISSUES AROUND FOOD SECURITY OF
OUR STUDENTS AND OTHER THINGS
WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR STUDENTS OF
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. THAT
IT'S.
THE MOST EFFICIENT MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ENSURE OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO.
ABUNDANT.
NUTRITIOUS AND AFFORDABLE FOOD
IS BY VIRTUE OF THE BILL PLAN SO
BILLS THE CONSTITUENTS WOULD
RAISE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M CHAIR DURACELL BE ON BEHALF
OF THE CAL STATE SOON
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO DO NOT HAVE
A POSITION ON THE BILL ON AND WE
DO APPRECIATE THE IDEA OF GIVING
STUDENTS CHOICE.
WHERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE KNOW THAT FORTY ONE
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS IN THE
CSU SUFFER FROM FOOD INSECURITY
AND OUR CONCERN IS THAT GIVEN
THAT CHOICE ON STUDENTS WITHOUT
A MEAL PLAN MIGHT? CHOOSE TO
JOIN THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM FROM FOOD
INSECURITY SAU THANK YOU.
ERICA REMAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE TO DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION. IN ADDITION TO THE
CONCERNS AROUND FOOD AND
SECURITY AT OUR CAMPUSES ARE
AVERAGE UNDERGRADUATE SIZES
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED WE HAVE SOME
FAIRLY SMALL CAMPUSES. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT SHOULD ENOUGH
STUDENTS OPT OUT WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FOOD SERVICES
BECAUSE WE COULD NOT GET A
PROVIDER OR WE WILL HAVE TO
BRING A IN HOUSE. RAISING COSTS
FOR EVERYBODY ON CAMPUS
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AS BAKER.
THANK YOUR AS CHAIR AND THANK
YOU DOCTOR CHOI.
IT YEAH CERTAINLY SEE A GREAT.
BENEFIT TO PARENTS JUST BEING
ABLE TO SEE HOW COST PLAY OUT I
I DO ALSO HAVE HOWEVER MY
DISTRICT ST MARY'S COLLEGE ONE
OF THE SMALLER DISTRICTS THAT
IS.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE APPLICATION
OF THIS TO THEM IN THEIR THEIR
ABILITY TO BE FLEXIBLE WITH
THEIR SINS IN THEIR OWN WAY AND
AND WHAT THEY OFFER WHAT THEY
DON'T OFFER.
.
AND I WENT I WENT IF YOU CAN
ADDRESS THE CONCERN ABOUT. ABOUT
THAT KNOWING THAT SOME PARENTS
WILL SAY I I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT MY KIDS ARE GOING TO GET A
MEAL EVEN IF THEY DON'T EAT IT.
IF THEY DON'T THINK IT IS BETTER
THAN PIZZA. WHATEVER ELSE IT IS.
AND IF YOU ARE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE.
FOLKS HAVE COME UP IN THE
TRAINER'S AREA TO.
A VISIT WITH THEM ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS.
I THINK THIS SOB BAYLOR HAS DONE
NOTHING TO DO.
WITH THE UP PARENT COLORLESS
CHILDREN'S SAW OPTION TO BUY
INTO.
ULTIMATE PLANS SO COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY OR OR FOR.
SIMPLY I'M ASKING.
UNLESS A SEPARATE.
BECAUSE SO WE KNOW THEY WOULDN'T
ALL.
HOW MUCH THE METED OUT WOULD
COST THEM?
WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE FUNDED IS
TO GATHER? AND OUT THERE SO NO
OPTION FOR EXAMPLE WHEN I LIVED
DOT. THAT THAT.
LOUISIANA STATE UNIVERSITY
DORMITORY CHEAPEST A DORMITORY I
LIVED AND.
I THOUGHT IT WAS NOT REQUIRED
FOR ME TO BUY THEM IN A PLAN.
I WAS ABLE TO LOOK BY INCIDENTS
MASTERS OF SOME SEMESTERS I
COULD NOT THE. MAN I COULD NOT
THE BY INTO ULTIMATE PLANS SO.
EITHER A I GO TO STUDENT OUR
UNION WHICH HAS SO ABUNDANCE OF
* CAFETERIA STYLE YOU CAN
PICK AND CHOOSE SAFE I HAVE MORE
MONEY ACTON CHOOSE TO THIRTY
FOUR PANTRIES. WHEN ALICE SAW IN
ALL POOR THAN I EACH WAS ON THE
RISE SO WHAT WHAT SHOULD.
SO ONE BOWL.
THAT THOUGH THE SUSTAIN ME
AND THAT THAT.
GAVE ME OPTION TO SAVE MONEY I
CAN AFFORD TO SO I THINK WITH
THIS OPTION GIVES UP.
RATHER THAN BECAUSE WE ALL TALK
ABOUT THE COLLEGE COST IS SO TOO
HIGH UP FOR PEOPLE TO ATTEND THE
COLLEGE.
SO ARE A.
I DON'T MEAN NUTRISYSTEM MANNER.
HAVE BEEN NOT TALKED ABOUT. WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IT THE
HOWEVER. ARE NOT BEING ABLE TO
ATTEND THE POLITICS OUT IN OUR
MORE ECONOMICAL. ARE A CHOICE
OUT THAT THEY CAN EVEN CREATE.
AND ALSO THERE FOR A WE ARE NOT
ASKING.
STUDENTS ARE NOT TO BUY INTO OUR
WHAT COLLEGES NOT TO PROVIDE THE
NUTRITIOUS ME OUTSIDE. OF THE
DOOR.
COST WOULD BE THIS SEMESTER NEXT
SEMESTER WILL BE THE SAME SAME
NUTRITION HOWEVER I'M ONLY
ASKING. ARE A SEPARATE.
HOUSING COSTS OF WORDS ESTIMATE
COSTA AND LET THEM KNOW AND ARE.
IF I CHOOSE TO LIVE ON CAMPERS.
I DON'T HAVE TO BUY INTIMATE
PLAN FOR WHATEVER REASON AND SAW
A THAT THE I MAY HAVE A KITCHEN
NAKED DOT A KITCHEN AMENITIES OF
SOME SOME UNIVERSITIES TO
HOUSING.
WELL AS I MENTIONED THE DO WE
HAVE THAT THE BUSTIER THEY HAVE
TO.
UP BY INTO ME TO PLAN TO LEAVE
ONE THAT DOES THE TEMPEST.
SO AND THE DEPEND UPON
UNIVERSITIES SIR SOME URBAN
UNIVERSITIES ARE OUTSIDE THIS OR
CONSERVE OUR.
IT A FAST FOOD THOUGH LOW
FACILITIES SO RESTAURANTS OR
WHATEVER SO IT IS ARE NOTSIMPLY
PROVIDING THE TRANSPARENCY AND
THEN OPTION FOR THE PARENTS SO
AND THE STUDENTS TO TO CHOOSE
FROM.
TO THE.
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT OR THE
ASSOCIATION AND PET COLLEGES
CONCERNED THAT PARTICULAR FOR
THE SMALLER COLLEGES THAT.
THEY GIVEN THE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THAT THEY HAVE A MAY HAVE
A DIFFICULT TIME OFFERING.
ECONOMICAL FOOD TO THOSE WHO
CHOOSE OF TWO MAY OPT OUT WHAT
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE RESPONSE
TO THEIR CONCERNS THAT THEY'VE
RAISED.
I THINK THAT IS SO.
A INSTANCE ALMOST SOUNDS LIKE
BUT WE NOT BENEFIT THAT BY
SENDING THE MINUTE PLAN THAT TO
SUBSIDIZE SUCH NOT ELECTING
FUNDING SO FOR THE GENERAL FUND.
BUT NOW WHAT ABOUT THE STUDENTS
I THINK GOOD VASO
INSTITUTIONALLY OUT THEY NEED TO
SOLVE OUR. OUR THE SUSTAINABLE
THE BUDGET ISSUES UP BUT NOT
HERE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STUDENTS ARE AFFORDABILITY
ATTENDING THE UNIVERSITY. S. ARE
NOT NOW OVER CHARGED A THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO MAY MAKE A DIFFERENCE SO TO
THEM.
SO WE ARE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE NUTRITION THAT I USE A
HOWEVER.
A IT IS AN OPTION IF THEY ARE
CONCERNED THAT IF THEY CAN GET
THOSE SCHOLARSHIPS ARE. YOU KNOW
ALONE SO BY ALL MEANS SO FOR
THEM TO BUY THEIR MADE PLANS ON
KNOWING THAT THE HOW MUCH EXTRA
COSTA. A IT IT WILL COST THEM TO
BUY PUMP CAMPUS PROVIDED MALES
YEAH I THINK THE I APPLAUD THE
EFFORT TO BE STUDENT CENTRIC SO
THAT THEY CAN DECIDE WHAT TO DO
I HOPE THAT AND CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE IT. THIS INTERACTING
AND VISITING WITH THE.
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED A CONCERN ABOUT THIS.
AS I SHARE IT AND I HOPE TO BE
A CHANCE TO FIND AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THEM ON
THAT ONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOU GOT.
I IS THERE SOMEONE WHO I IS FROM
I GUESS THE CSU OUR I MAYBE THAT
THE INDEPENDENT SCHOOLS TO THAT
THAT COULD ANSWER QUESTIONS I
DON'T.
DON'T SEE ANYONE.
STILL UP HERE.
THANK YOU I I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE ECONOMY OF SCALE
OR EVEN A LITTLE BETTER SO I AM.
I MEAN YOU KNOW I AT WHAT POINT
DID TO OPT OUT START TO ACTUALLY
HAVE AN APPRECIABLE IMPACT ON
COSTS AYE AND HOW HOW MUCH HOW
BIG WILL THE IMPACT BE.
AT SARAH.
SEWER EIGHT. FOR THE INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY
HOW MANY INSTITUTIONS WAITED.
LOSE THE ABILITY BUT FOR
INSTANCE.
MILLS COLLEGE IN OAKLAND.
HAD RECENTLY BROUGHT IT IN FROM.
BEING FULLY IN THE HOUSE TO
SAVE THE STUDENTS MONEY. AND
THEY'RE BARELY MEETING THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE FOR THEIR
PROVIDER. SO IF THEY HAVE
STUDENTS OPTING OUT THEY WOULD
HAVE TO BRING IT BACK IN BECAUSE
THE PROVIDERS
WEREN'T WILLING TO COME IN
WITHOUT THE GUARANTEE. AYE SOME
AND I CAN FIND ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AS TO HOW MANY OF
OUR CAMPUSES.
THAT WOULD BE BUT TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE HAVE TO BRING IT IN
HOUSE BECAUSE THE SIZE OF THE
INSTITUTIONS OBVIOUSLY IMPACTS
COSTS.
I'M.
PLUGIN ALEX RAISE OF THE CSU AND
I THINK I CAN SAY GENERALLY IS
THAT.
TOP PERSON PROBLEM.
I THINK IT'S A GENERALLY IS
THAT OUR DINING AND.
THROUGH OUR AND HOUSING
SERVICES ARE BOTH AUXILIARIES
ARE SELF SUPPORT.
SO THEY ARE NONPROFIT ENTITIES
THEY DON'T MAKE A PROFIT OFF OF
STUDENTS.
AND WHEN THEY ARE NEGOTIATING
THEIR CONTRACTS WITH VENDORS
LIKE THE DECKS ON OTHERS ARE
OFTENTIMES IN THOSE CONTRACTS
THERE ARE BASS LINE REVENUE
GUARANTEES THAT AT THAT.
THAT WILL LOCK IN THE PRICE
POINTS FOR THERE'D THAT EITHER
PURCHASING THE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE RECEIVING THOSE
CONTRACTS AND SO ON I MEAN IF IF
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
.
YOU KNOW SANSOME NUMBERS CRUNCH
TIME KIND OF WHITE CHANGE ON ONE
SIDE EQUALS CAO ONE ON THE OTHER
I DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME I'D BE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP AND CHECK IN
WITH OUR FOLKS WHO RUN OUR
AUXILIARIES ON OUR CAMPUSES.
BUT GENERALLY OUR CONCERN IS
THAT IF THERE IS.
A SIGNIFICANT.
OR NOTABLE REDUCTION IN
STUDENTS UTILIZING OUR DINING
SERVICES THAT THAT IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE MADE UP.
LIKELY IN THE FORM OF
INCREASING OUR PRICES FOR
STUDENTS WHO DO OPT INTO THOSE
THING HOW MANY STUDENTS WE TALK
ABOUT WHEN HE'S UP THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY VARIES A LOT I BET ON
CAMPUS CAMPUS BUT WHAT'S THE
GENERAL. BALLPARK THIRD STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING DINING SERVICES.
I'LL GOSH I HAVE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU I AFTER I CHECK WITH
OUR FOLKS NINE SENT THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS I'M SURE IT AND MAKING
I WOULD ASSUME SO AND AGAIN I I
DON'T WANT TO COMMIT TO NUMBERS
OUT WITHOUT CHECKING MAY BE
HAPPY DEFAULT THEIR OFFICE. OKAY
YEAH I I STRUGGLE TO SEE A
LITTLE BIT HOW THIS IS MUCH OF A
PROBLEM FOR THE CSU. AND I YOU
KNOW FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
WORSE SETTING POLICY FOR AND.
I'M NOT SURE I LIKE THE IDEA
THAT YOU'RE FORCING SOME
STUDENTS TO HAVE THIS MEAL PLAN
ORDER SUBSIDIZE.
THE COST FOR EVERYONE I MEAN IN
THEORY WE CAN DO THAT WITH ALL
KINDS OF THINGS RIGHT YOU DID
FOR STUDENTS TO BUY THEIR
LAPTOPS FROM THE UNIVERSITIES
THAT WE CAN GET BETTER. BOLT
DISCOUNTING PRICE.
ON THE OTHER HAND.
I DO THINK THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT PRIVATE
UNIVERSITY.
THAT YOU KNOW WE WOULD HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO EXPERIMENT WITH
DIFFERENT WAYS OF SETTING UP
CAMPUS LIFE.
MAYBE THERE'S AN ARGUMENT THAT
HAVE A CAMPUS WANTS TO SAY THAT
WE WANNA I HAVE EVERYONE TAKE
THEIR MEALS IN THE SAME PLACES
LIVING ON CAMPUS IN ORDER TO
BUILD COMMUNITY.
THEN MAYBE THEY OUGHT TO HAVE
THAT OPTIONS I DO KNOW THAT
DOCTOR CHOI WOULD YOU BE. OPEN
TO AN AMENDMENT THAT MIGHT MAKE
THIS APPLIED TO.
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS I
BET MAYBE NOT THOSE THAT ARE
PRIVATE IN THE RECEIVING CAL
GRANTS.
THIS BILL LAW SPECIFIES SAW IN
NEON.
INDEPENDENT PROFIT THE
UNIVERSITY IS SO.
.
STUDENTS OF RECEIVING OUR STATE
FUNDING.
IF THEY'LL RECEIVE A STATE
FUNDING I THINK THAT THEY ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO.
IT'S ABOUT INCLUDE ANY.
.
PRIVATE UNIVERSITY THAT HAS
STUDENTS WHO A.
RECEIVE CONFERENCE CORRECT.
YEAH AS ENEMIES OF THEY RECEIVE
ARE NOW STATE FUNDING SHOULD BE
SUBJECTED TO.
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN MY
OPTION TO I HAVE A SOME DIALOGUE
THAT.
HOW?
?
I MEAN. THIS IS UP BALANCE ACT
JUST AS SELF NOT TO OVAL TEAR
ON.
THEM MOTHER GOOSE I.
A I MEAN THAT WE CANNOT WE'RE
GONNA HOW.
UNIVERSITIES SAYS.
STAY HEALTHY.
AT THE SAME TIME A I'M MORE
SPEAKING FROM THESE CHILDREN
MISS POINT OF VIEW. OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY AND OF
TRANSPARENCY WHY AM I SUPPOSED
TO JUST BECAUSE I LEAVE ARE. OUT
ON THE CAMPUS HOUSING NOT IN MY
FORCED TO BUY IN TO MEET PLAN.
WHERE I CAN GET BY MUCH LESS
THAT WOULD SAY BLOW CONGRESS UP
THOUSAND DOLLARS?
YEAH ALRIGHT Y. I GENERALLY LIKE
THE IDEA I'M HAPPY TO VOTE TODAY
THAT I MOVE FORWARD I WOULD AND
COULD YOU TO TALK TO THE FOLKS
AT THE AYE INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
AND I SEE WHETHER THIS SOLUTION
IS.
IT'S FITTING FOR THEM IS A MIGHT
BE FIRST THE CS USE THANK.
MR WITH. YES I I THINK THERE'S
THERE WERE A LOT OF THE.
GOOD POINTS BROUGHT UP TODAY
AND I DO LIKE THE FIRST.
PART OF YOUR BILL BREAKING OUT
THE THE.
ROOM AND BOARD AND THE.
THAT THE MEAL PLANS AND THEN
YOU TO BUT I THINK OTHER.
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP
LIKE FOOD INSECURITY ARE.
I THINK THOSE ARE RELEVANT
ISSUES LIKE I DO THINK THE
COLLEGES SHOULD OFFER
FLEXIBILITY SO. UP POTENTIALLY
LOWER PRICED MEAL PLANS BUT NOW
I LOOK AT THIS IN THE EXTREME IF
YOU END UP.
BOB IN THE DORM SETTING WITH NO
COOKING OF FACILITIES AND A LOT
OF THESE STORMS.
AND I HAD THREE KIDS THAT WENT
THROUGH COLLEGE THEY'RE VERY
CROWDED THREE PEOPLE TO A ROOM.
THEY ALL TURNED OUT MEAL PLAN
AND NOW THEY HAVE THEIR ROOMS
FILLED WITH.
FOOD YOUR YOUR POTENTIALLY GOING
TO HAVE RODENT ISSUES YOU COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE FOOD SAFETY
ISSUES AND I THINK IT'S.
NOT UNREASONABLE FOR COLLEGES TO
TO TRY TO AVOID THAT SITUATION.
SO I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE THAT OR NOT BUT IT'S.
.
THOSE COLLEGE DORM ROOMS THAT
I'VE BEEN TO DON'T NEED
ADDITIONAL LOAVES OF BREAD OR
JARS OF PEANUT BUTTER OF.
FLOATING AROUND THAT SOMEBODY
DOESN'T HAVE.
ANY MEAL PLAN AT ALL YEAH I CAN
SEE THAT UP POSSIBILITY.
BUT.
.
ARE. THERE SOME.
AS THE CAMPUS PROVIDED A
HOUSING. OUT UNITS OUT WITH ME
EVEN COOKING FACILITIES SO WHEN
THEY AND.
STUDENTS ARE LEAVING THEIR THEY
HAVE NO OPTION SO THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT THEY ARE LIKELY IF
THEY CAN USE THEIR OUT KITCHEN
FACILITIES ABOUT THAT THOSE OUT
WITHOUT IT BUT I THINK THIS IS A
MATTER OF OUR. COLLEGES SETTING
THE OPEN POLICIES ON THE COOKING
ITSELF AND UBER AND WHAT ALLOW
DECADE IN THE DORMITORIES CELL
WITH NO KIDS AND I MANAGED.
AND ALLEN SO I MEAN I'M IN
AGREEMENT WITH THAT BUT
CERTAINLY WITH MY KIDS AND THEY
WERE NOT FORCE TO TAKE A MEAL
PLAN IF THERE WERE COOKING
FACILITIES THEY WERE THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO TAKE A MEAL PLAN IF
THERE WEREN'T ANY COOKING
FACILITIES.
THE FBI AREAS SAW IS A FIRE
HAZARD THOUGH RULED ON. WHATEVER
YEAH ISSUE SANITARY ISSUES SO WE
CAN FACE IT BUT I THINK AUTO SET
CAN BE SET UP BY THE COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATION YOU KNOW HOW TO
PREVENT. SUCH POTENTIAL
PROBLEMS.
DOCTOR WEBER. OKAY COULD THE YES
I APPRECIATE THIS AND AND
OBVIOUSLY THE ISSUE OF OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND. AND CAMPUSES IN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
ARE YOU SAYING BECAUSE ANNOUNCED
OUT SLIGHTLY CONFUSED ARE YOU
SAYING THAT THIS WOULD BE
CONTINGENT UPON. WHETHER NOT THE
DORMITORIES HAD COOKING
FACILITIES ARE NOT BECAUSE THIS
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY SAY THAT IN
THIS BILL SO.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING NO NO
NO WE ARE NOT REALLY FOCUSING
UPON IN THE LIVING. FACILITIES
WITH UP TO TEN FACILITATE ONE
NOT THAT THOSE AT THE EXAMPLES
CITED I'M A STUDENT HAPPENS TO
LEAVE BUT EVEN. A IN A HOUSING
UNIT SO WITH THE KITCHEN
FACILITIES SO IF THAT'S SO. A
LOT BUT THAT. THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S A COLLEGE OR A
INSTITUTIONALLY OWN THE
FACILITIES THAT THEY HAVE NO.
THEY DID TO TWO THINGS ARE ON
I'M NOT EMPHASIZE SAID THAT IS
TARA THE TRANSPARENCY PARENTS
ARE. UP WOULD KNOW WHAT THE OUT.
PAYING.
AND THOSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
THEY THEY ARE IT.
UP BY DIDN'T WANT BY OUT. GAY
AND OUT WE ARE NOT THE FOCUSING
UPON ANY UNITS SELL WITH FEE OF
UP PUTTING FACILITIES WHY NOT.
AND. WHAT IF IT FOR WITH THICK
KNOTTED TO FISTS EDITED SO I
MEAN THAT CAN THAT CAN BUY AND?
AND.
WITHOUT THAT TIM FACILITIES TO
OBVIOUSLY FOR THE CONVENIENCE
OF.
I DON'T THINK ARE IN ALL MY
ANTICIPATION IS THAT DATA.
NEVER BE DRAMATIC CHANGE.
BUT THE I THINK BY BY DOING
THIS WAY A COTTAGES TO WOULD BE
MORE. COST CONSCIOUS
AND.
LET THE OUR STUDENTS TO KNOW
ABOUT THE WHAT THE OUTLYING INTO
AND DONE ANY CALCULATION.
FOR THE FOOD CONTRACTING DE
WOULD KNOW HOW MUCH IT COST US
SO IT IS NOT TOO DIFFICULT TO
SEPARATE THE HOUSING UNITS.
A AND UP AGAINST OUR.
THE MID SET THE PROFILE.
OKAY.
.
I THINK THEY'RE PROBABLY SOME.
ROOM FOR OBVIOUSLY SAW MINUTES
OF THIS IS SOMETHING BECAUSE
I THINK THE DOCUMENT AT LEAST
THE ONE I'M LOOKING AT SAYS THAT
WE WOULD PROHIBIT.
CITIES FROM ACQUIRING STUDENT
HAVE A CAMPUS MEAL PLAN AS A
CONDITION OF LIVING IN
INSTITUTIONALLY OPERATE HOUSING
SO I THINK THAT'S LIKE ACROSS
THE BOARD VERSUS SAYING. IT
UNLESS YOU IF YOU KNEW IT WAS
ONLY DESIGNED FOR THOSE PLACES
THAT THAT DUMB.
BUT DON'T HAVE OR DOES IT DON'T
HAVE COOKING FACILITIES OR
WHATEVER THEN AND THIS THAT THEN
APPLY THEM I MEAN.
I I.
BECAUSE THIS IS PRETTY A
STANDARD TO LOOK LIKE THAT
EVERYONE WOULD HAVE TO
INSTITUTIONS WOULD HAVE TO.
REQUIRE UP HAVE TO GIVE
STUDENTS THE OPTION OF HAVING A
PLAN AND NO PLAN THAT'S WHAT THE
STATE IS SO EVIDENTLY IF YOU. IF
YOU ALTERING IT NOW AND SAYING
ONLY IF THEY HAVE COOKING
FACILITIES THAT'S A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
REALITY AND AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS MOST CAMPUSES AT YOU KNOW
AND AND I'VE BEEN ON A BUNCH
CAMPUSES BATTLE IS A FACULTY
BUT.
AS OF THE THINGS MOST CAMPUSES
UP IN THE DORMITORY IN.
LIVING KIND OF.
AREA EVEN THE LARGE ONES HAVE A
MULTITUDE OF OPTIONS
STUDENTS I MEAN IT WOULD BE NICE
IF THEY DID BREAK OUT THE COST
WHATEVER YOU COULD KIND OF
FIGURED OUT TO SELL. BUT MOST OF
THE TIME WE GO TO THESE
CAMPUSES.
THEY HAVE ALL KINDS OF
OPERATIONS AND AND OPTIONS FOR
STUDENTS OF THAT ARE THERE AND
BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE. OF THE
LARGER CAMPUS IS NOT ALWAYS THE
SMALLER ONES HAVE OF NEW
FACILITIES NOT THAT HAVE KIND OF
APARTMENT LIVING WITH WITH
STUDENTS IN THE CIRCLE AND ALL
THIS OTHER KIND OF STUFF AS WELL
AS SOME OTHER THINGS. AND THEN
THEY HAVE SOME THE TRADITIONAL
AREAS OF PEOPLE LIVE IN BECOMES
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO MANDATE THAT
THAT WE THAT EVERYBODY HAS TO
HAVE A CERTAIN THING.
ITEMSI FOUND CAMPUS AS TO BE
ALMOST EXTREMELY ACCOMMODATING
NOW MUCH MORE WHEN I WITH THE
COLLEGE YOU KNOW THAT WASN'T
THERE WAS A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY.
BUT DID NOW WHEN I GO ON CAMPUS
AS YOU FIND ALL KINDS OF LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS AND APARTMENTS AND.
ALL THEY ALSO HAVE MULTIPLE
PLANS WHERE YOU CAN HAVE LIKE
ONE MEAL A DAY OR TWO MEALS A
DAY OR WHATEVER.
AND AND THE STUDENTS HAVE A
TENDENCY TO FAMILIES PICK WHAT
THEY THINK IS BEST AT THIS POINT
BUT. I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS
CLEAR ENOUGH ABOUT.
WHAT I WANT TO MANDATE THAT
EVERYONE HAS TO HAVE TO SET THE
SEPARATE HAVE AN OPTION TO HAVE
A MEAL PLAN NO MEAL PLAN?
BECAUSE I AB AS POINTED OUT BY
MY COLLEAGUE HERE.
YOU KNOW DORMS CAN GET TO BE
SOME REALLY TRASHY PLACES IF YOU
FELT STUDENTS TRYING TO COOK
INTO MY BEEN AND BELONG TO
PEOPLE AT THAT PLACE THAT WAS A
DISASTER.
SET THINGS ON FIRE.
YOU KNOW TRIED TO COOK YOU KNOW
BUGS AND STUFF RENDON EVERYWHERE
YOU CAN IMAGINE A STUDENTS
MAKING TACKLES IN A ROOM ONE
TIME I MEAN JUST. ALL KINDS OF
STUFF AND THAT YOU WOULD WANT IN
A NORMAL LIVING CONDITION GIVEN
THE CONDITIONS OF THE DORMITORY
BEING A VERY SMALL ROOM SO. I'M
NOT SURE IF I WANT TO MANDATE
THAT EVERYBODY HAS TO HAVE THE
OPTION OF NOT HAVING FOOD
BECAUSE. I DON'T LET KIND OF
PLAYS WITH THE THE OVERALL
GENERAL PLAN THAT'S THERE BUT IF
YOU. EXITING OUT THOSE OF THE
PLACES THEM THAT'S NOT REALLY
REFLECTED HERE AND THEN WHAT
I'VE READ IS THE NARRATIVE YEAR.
AND IF YOU INTEND TO OP THEM OUT
AND I THINK THAT WOULD BE. TO
MAKE THE BILL A LITTLE BIT
BETTER FOR THOSE WHO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT SAFETY ISSUES AND
LIVING CONDITIONS IN DORMITORIES
AND NOWADAYS SO MANY.
UNIVERSITIES SO TO OFFER MANY
DEFEND ME AS IF TEN MAYOR SO
TWENTY MINUTES OF THIRD ARMY OF
WHATEVER SO. IT WOULD NOT
SIMPLY.
DISA AS SENSE OF THIS BIT LISTA
OF GAVE THE STUDENT OPTION TO
BUY IN LA OPT OUT THE.
AND TO SPECIFY HOW MUCH
BUT THE MERE PLANNED THE.
OP BUYING IN NOT JUST THEM
MANDATED THAT JUST BECAUSE HER
ONE CHOICES TO LIVE UP.
NOW IN THE CAMPUS OWNED A
HOUSING THE MUTED PLANET SIDE
NOT THE MANDATORY WITH THE
NORMAL DEVIATION HOW MUCH IS IT
ALL BUT THEY ARE SEPARATED A
FULL HOUSE SINGLE WORD THEIR
NAILS COOKING FACILITIES TO NO
REFRIGERATION. OR OKAY ALSO A SO
WE ARE WE ARE NOT FOCUSING UPON
THE FACILITIES SO WITH IT.
TING FACILITIES SARAH MANAGES
ONE NOT THAT THAT'S SEVERE
OPTION EVENING FOR WHICH YOU ARE
COOKING AMENITIES SOME MAY
CHOOSE TO BUY AND LITTLE SIMPLY
GIVE THE OPTION TO THE STUDENTS
SO IF THE.
HAPPENED TO CHOOSE SO ABOVE THE
TYPICAL FAT THEMSELVES STEP
BECAUSE OF OUR. COOKING A MANIC
TO SOUTH VALUABLE APARTMENT TYPE
OF HOUSING. ARE UP BUT THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT BE MANDATED THAT.
SO WHAT COULD DISAPPEAR WAS SAW
ARE NOT IDEA WAS TO PURPLE LISTA
ARGUMENTS THE SET SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL TO GET USUALLY SO
WE CAN GET A QUORUM.
MEDINA PRESENT.
BAKER.
ARAMBULA BLOOM CHVEZ IRWIN.
KILEY.
LEVINE.
LOW PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
WEBER HERE.
I THINK YOU HAVE THAT WARM.
AS MUCH AS I.
YOU KNOW LET'S
THANK YOU FOR THE.
DO DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED BY MISTER KILEY.
SECOND BY MISTER SANTIAGO.
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD.
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS.
TO PASS.
WITH A FIRST IN A SECOND THEM
THAT THE MOTION WAS DUE PASSED.
WITH AMENDMENTS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
YES
UP IT.
I KNOW I THINK WE WE NEED
CLARIFICATION ON WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE.
AND.
I BECAUSE I THINK THERE HAS BEEN
SOME CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
WILLINGNESS TO NOT ONLY VISIT
WITH THE.
INTERESTED PARTIES WHO CAME IN
MENTION THERE THE ISSUE RIGHT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
HERE.
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THIS MEASURE APPLIES TO BOTH
UNIVERSITIES. AND COLLEGES.
ON PAGE TWO.
LINE SIX NINE AND REPLACE THE
TERM UNIVERSITY OPERATED HOUSING
WITH INSTITUTIONAL. OPERATED
HOUSING.
YEAH INSTITUTIONAL IT DONE NOT
JUST A UNIVERSITY TO TO NOT MAKE
IT MEAN THAT DATA. OR EVEN TO
YOUR COLLEGE WHAT FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY ASSIST SO
INSTITUTION MANZA ACADEMICALLY.
YEAH INSTITUTIONALLY OWNED
HOUSES SO THE AUTHOR AGREES TO
THE AMENDMENT YES I READ OF.
THOSE ARE THE AMENDMENT.
SO THE MOTION AGAIN IS DUE
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA NOT VOTING.
BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA BLOOM CHAVEZ.
IRWIN.
IRWIN NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
NO.
WEBER NO.
FIVE TWO IT'S ON CALL
AND I WILL GO BACK TO THE.
FIRST BILL.
SECOND.
.
ITEM TO DO SO THE MOTION IS.
DO PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MADAM SECRETARY GOOD CALL THE
ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM CHVEZ
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE KILEY.
CUT KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE
LOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
VOTERS NINE ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT.
THANK THANK EVERYONE.
AND NEXT UP.
ITEM TEN MOSTLY MON.
RESOLUTION.
WELCOME. THANK YOU CHAIR MEDINA
AND MEMBERS A LOT TODAY WE HAVE
A RESOLUTION ACR ONE FIFTY THAT
RECOGNIZES MARCH EIGHTEENTH ADD
THROUGH MARCH TWENTY FOURTH AS
A.
DUAL ENROLLMENT WE CAN
CALIFORNIA DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAMS OFFER PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE INCOMPLETE
CHALLENGING COLLEGE COURSEWORK
WHILE STILL ENROLLED IN HIGH
SCHOOL. MODUS BILL.
BEING FEW WITH ME TODAY I DO
HAVE A DOCTOR AT A WIDE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS FOR THE LONG BEACH
COLLEGE PROMISE I IN SUPPORT OF
THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
A.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE LONG
BEACH COLLEGE PROMISE WHICH
PROVIDE SEAMLESS EDUCATION FROM
PRE KINDERGARTEN TO. A
COMPLETION OF A POST SECONDARY
CREDENTIAL OF A STUDENT'S
CHOICE.
THIS WAS AUTHORIZED BY SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY UP FROM ALAN
LOWENTHAL A MADE INTO LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. A AND IT WAS
MADE PERMANENT BY.
PATRICK O'DONNELL SAID ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE.
I SAY ALL OF THAT TO SAY THAT I
THINK THE ISSUE OF DAHLE
ENROLLMENT IS AN IMPORTANT ONE
IN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LIMON FOR BRINGING IT TO ALL THE
ATTENTION OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH LONG BEACH
STUDENTS
HAVE SHOWN A COUPLE OF THINGS.
ONE IS THE DUMA ROMAN OPENS UP
ACCESS TO STUDENTS WHO MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE HAVE COLLEGE GOING
EXPERIENCES.
THE SECOND THING IS THAT I
REALIZE THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
INFORM STUDENTS PARENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF DUAL ENROLLMENT.
IN LONG BEACH OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE IN
COLLEGE GOING RATES TO BOTH LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE AND CAL STATE
LONG BEACH.
INCLUDING SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
WHILE WE'RE STILL GATHERING DATA
TO UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF DOOM
ENROLLMENT IN THESE INCREASES.
IT IS THE OLD ALIGNMENT OF
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAS ALLOWED
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO CONNECT
WITH INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING.
WHEN I VISIT HIGH SCHOOLS TO
TALK TO STUDENTS ABOUT COLLEGE.
WHEN I IT SPECIFICALLY A TALK TO
THEM ABOUT THE ETHNIC STUDIES
DUAL ENROLLMENT COURSES THAT WE
OFFER FROM CAL STATE LONG BEACH
TO LONG BEACH UNIFIED. IT HELPS
THEM CONNECT DIRECTLY WITH
COLLEGE FACULTY.
A COLLEGE PERSONNEL AND IT HELPS
DEMYSTIFY THE COLLEGE PROCESS
FOR THEM.
I ALSO WORK WITH HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AND OTHER SITE
ADMINISTRATORS
TO HELP DEMYSTIFY THAT PROCESS
AS WELL.
OF THESE BENEFITS ECHO SOME OF
THE RESEARCH UNDERGONE ROMAN
WHICH SHOWS THAT. IT IMPROVE
STUDENT'S COLLEGE READINESS.
IN IT INCREASES THEIR POST
SECONDARY ACCESS AND
PERSISTENCE.
AND THERE HAS BEEN RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS THAT OUR RATES OF COLLEGE
COMPLETION ARE INCREASING AS
WELL.
THE STUDENTS I TALKED TO SAY
THAT THEY HAVE INCREASED THEIR
MOTIVATION TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
AND IT GIVES THEM A TASTE OF
WHAT COLLEGES LIKE.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY
TESTIMONY.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRUCE BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WHO HAVE
A SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY CLEANERS.
SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I WILL GIVE SOME
COMMENTS.
I I WAS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
AND A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TEACHER
AND AS A MATTER FACT. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY.
I TEACH
THE HISTORY OF MEXICO.
UP ON MY HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUS.
AFTER SCHOOL
SO I AM VERY STRONGLY IN FAVOR
OF DOING ENROLLMENT. I'VE SEEN
ALL THOSE THINGS THAT YOU
STATED.
I HAPPEN WITH HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS
AND AND AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT. OFTENTIMES.
.
NOT ALL.
UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF DUAL
ENROLLMENT SO I I VERY MUCH. IN
FAVOR OF THE RESOLUTION AND EVEN
ASK THE AUTHOR TO THINK ABOUT
MAKING IN THE THIRD WEEK. OF
MARCH OF EVERY YEAR DUAL
ENROLLMENT WE. THANK YOU DULY
NOTED CHAIR. AND WITH THAT I
WILL.
AS A SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM CHVEZ
IRWIN.
IRWIN I.
KILEY
KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
BLOOM I.
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT.
ITEM ONE.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I THINK FOR ALLOW E TO
PRESENT ON ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN TODAY. AS
WE KNOW GROWING STUDENT OUT FOR
RECENT COLLEGE GRADUATES IS A
CONCERNING ISSUE THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE. MUST
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
VINCE IS SUPER COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS FOUND OUT THE
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENT DEBT FOR A
CALIFORNIA GRADUATE AT PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGES IS.
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT A WITH THE
TOTAL DEBT AVERAGE OF TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER GRADUATE STUDENT.
STUDENT LOAN COMPANIES OFTEN
PROVIDE RECENT GRADUATES WITH
THE SIX MONTH GRACE PERIOD
BEFORE THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
BEGAN THEIR LOAN REPAYMENT.
HOWEVER SIX MONTHS IS NOT ENOUGH
TIME FOR RECENT GRADUATES
WERE OFTEN FACED WITH
DIFFICULTIES ENTERING THE
WORKFORCE AND ADJUSTING TO POST
COLLEGE LIFE.
THIS IS ALSO INSUFFICIENT TIME
TO CONSIDER THEIR CAREER OPTIONS
AND MAJOR LIFE EXPERIENCES SUCH
AS PURCHASING A HOME PERHAPS
MARRIAGE OR STARTER STARTING A
FAMILY. BEFORE HAVING TO TAKE ON
THIS HERCULEAN TASK OF REPAINT
OUR OF STUDENT LOANS.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WILL
PROVIDE UP TO TWO YEARS OF DEBT
RELIEF FOR FEDERAL STUDENT LOANS
TO RECENT COLLEGE GRADUATES WHO
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA. IT
REPLICATES AN EXISTING PROGRAM
THAT IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
STATE OF NEW YORK THIS BILL WILL
BE A PROVIDE OUR GRADUATES WITH
MORE TIME.
TO GIVE THEM TO PAY THE DOCTOR
FEDERAL STUDENT LOANS AND ALSO
ADDRESS ARE CRITICAL NEED AYE TO
HELP OUR STUDENTS THROUGH THIS
PROCESS SO COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
ARE MEDINA AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GERRY JERVIS AGAIN FOR THE
CALISTO.
TELL STATE SENATOR FEARS AND.
THANK YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES FOR ALLOWING US TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I WANNA TALK ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THAT CALIFORNIA KICKSTART MY
FUTURE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAMBY SPEAKING ABOUT THE
EQUITY
ISSUES REGARDING WHO NEEDS TO
TAKE OUT DEBT IN THE CSU.
AND POTENTIALLY A CHAIN AYE AND
POTENTIAL CHANGES TO LOAN
SUBSIDY AND FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
FOR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
LIKE THE CSU OUR TUITION IS
AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE COUNTRY
AND WHERE NEARLY TWO OUT OF
EVERY THREE STUDENTS DO NOT PAY
TUITION AT ALL DUE TO A
COMBINATION OF SYSTEM. STATE AND
FEDERAL AID PROGRAMS MANY ASSUME
THAT IT CSU DEGREE AS AFFORDABLE
YET FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS
CONTINUE TO FACE VERY REAL
CHALLENGE AS.
YEAH AFFORDING ALL OF THE COST
NECESSARY TO EARN A COLLEGE
DEGREE. THIS IS REFLECTED IN THE
DEBT BURDENS THAT FALL MORE
HEAVILY ON UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS IN THE CSU.
THE CELTICS IN ASSOCIATION IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE CUTS THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS PUBLISHED REPORT LAST
YEAR WHICH INVESTIGATED THE
ISSUE OF WHICH STUDENTS HOLD
THAT IN THE CSU.
IT FOUND THAT NEARLY EATEN TEN
STUDENTS WITH A BACHELORS DEGREE
WHO BORROWED HAD FAMILY INCOMES
NO GREATER THAN FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF WHITE STUDENTS HAD
THAT WHEN THEY GRADUATED FIFTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF HISPANIC AND
LATINO GRADUATES.
GUY DOT AND SEVENTY SIX PERCENT
OF BLACK OR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS GRADUATED WITH THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THE AVERAGE IN THE
CSU FOR GRADUATES IS BELOW THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE THIS REPORT
SHOWED THAT WHEN YOU SLICE A
NUMBER THE DEBT WAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HELD BY
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
FOR THIS REASON ALONE A PROGRAM
LIKE THE ONE CREATED BY AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO GIVE THE
STUDENTS A BETTER FINANCIAL
RELIEF. SO THAT HOPEFULLY THEY
WOULD NOT BE SADDLED WITH THE
DEBT THEY CAN.
POTENTIALLY BE STRUGGLING TO PAY
OFF FOR THE REST THEIR LIVES
ADDITIONALLY OUR ORGANIZATION AS
WELL AS MANY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT PROPOSALS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT MAY
NEGATIVELY IMPACT PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO
NEED TO TAKE OUT LOANS. OR WHO
HAVE DEBTS.
CURRENTLY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND PROPOSING
THERE FOR FY NINETEEN BUDGET ARE
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE.
AND ELIMINATION OF ALL
SUBSIDIZED LOANS FOR
UNDERGRADUATES ELIMINATION OF
THE PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM AND
ELIMINATING FEDERAL WORK STUDY
FOR GRADUATE STUDENTS.
ALL OF THESE CHANGES IF UP
IMPLEMENTED WOULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON STUDENTS
WHO TAKE OUT LOANS TO COMPLETE
THEIR EDUCATION AND GRADUATES
WHO HOLD THAT.
IN ADDITION WE DO HAVE A ALSO
DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT THE STATUS
OF THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU. AND THEIR
ABILITY TO BE A LAST LINE OF
DEFENSE FOR STUDENT BORROWERS
AND DEBT HOLDERS. EVEN THOUGH
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA ARE
LOOKING TO FILL THIS NEW GAP
WITH RESPECT TO FINANCIAL
PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
LOOKING TO PREEMPT STATES FROM
BEING ABLE TO REGULATE FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS LIKE STUDENT LOANS.
ALL OF THESE CHANGES AN IMPACT
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SHOW HOW
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL A PROGRAM
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA KICKSTART MY
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAM IS
NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER TO
PROVIDE A LEVEL RELIEF AND
PROTECTION FOR STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY TWEETERS.
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ONE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEE NOTE WIENERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
KILEY.
SO YOUR ON YOU YOUR ARGUMENT IS
THAT YOU HAVE A SIX MONTH GRACE
PERIOD THROUGH THE FEDERAL STERN
ONE.
PROGRAM I BUT WE NEED TO THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH TIME RIGHT.
SO I GUESS ONE APPROACH THAT WE
COULD TAKE IS THE STATE COULD
STEP IN AND TRY TO EXTEND THAT
GRACE PERIOD.
.
EITHER BY ASSUMING WHATEVER THE.
PAINFUL OF THE INTEREST IS OR
PERHAPS SOMETHING EVEN BE
NEGOTIATED. WITH THAT WITH
PROVIDERS UNDER THIS IS TAKING A
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND HAVING
THE STATE IS KIND OF STEP IN.
AND AND MAKE THE PAYMENTS ITSELF
I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY YOU OPTED
TO GO THAT DIRECTION IS THAT THE
WAY NEW YORK HAS A FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT IS ONE EXAMPLE.
THAT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN SO
WE CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO LOOK
AT THIS OPTION IS A WASTE HOW
OUR STUDENTS ARE RELIEVED DOT.
DOT.
RIGHT BUT THE IDEA IS TO EXTEND
THE GRACE PERIOD AND SO I'M
WONDERING.
.
IF THERE MIGHT BE A WAY TO DO
THAT WITHOUT THE STATE JUST
TAKING ON.
THAT THE PAYMENTS ITSELF.
I DO HAVE YOU EXPLORE THAT
OPTION WELL IT'S CERTAINLY A
MEASURE WE CAN LOOK AT IN THE
FUTURE.
OKAY.
YOU GUYS I THINK I DON'T NOT
WHITE THAT THIS APPROACH MIGHT
BE PREFERABLE.
OBVIOUSLY A GRACE PERIOD IS IS
IS VALUABLE BUT ON THAT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE INTERESTS THAT A
STUDENT HAS TO PAY I THINK FROM
FROM OUR ORGANIZATIONS
PERSPECTIVE THE IDEA OF
RELIEVING SOME OF THAT DEBT IS
EXTREMELY VALUABLE TO STUDENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I DO NOT BUT I JUST WANT SOME
CLARIFICATION.
THE.
SO FORWARD.
TWO YEARS WE WOULD MAKE THE
PAYMENT.
IS THAT RIGHT FOR UP TO TWENTY
FORM OF THE TWENTY FOUR MONTHS A
AFTER HOW LONG GENERAL YOU THAT
A LOAN DEBT IS WHAT HOW MANY
PARKING HOW MANY YEARS.
TEN YEARS. IT WOULD DEPEND I
MEAN THE AVERAGE DEBT LOAD OF
ITS IF YOU SEE IN THIS AROUND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
THING SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
IT JUST DEPENDS ON HOW LONG IT
TAKES ON THE PAY THAT BACK. OKAY
OKAY SO. I'LL BUT GENERALLY
THEY'RE GIVEN A AND INCOME
PAYMENT KIND OF SITUATION SO IT
PROBABLY IS A SMALL AMOUNT THAT
WOULD PAY. FOR THEM IS THAT
CORRECT PROBABLY SO SO THE IT'S
BASED OFF OF INCOME AND FAMILY
SIZE SO.
INDIVIDUALS A MAKE OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT NOT BE ABLE
TO QUALIFY FOR THIS PROGRAM OKAY
THEY MAKE THE OVER FIFTY NOT
THEIR PARENTS WHICH ONE IS IT
IT'S. THEM THEM SO THEY IN TERMS
OF JOB OKAY SO THAT.
NOT IT'S NOT THE PAYMENT BACK OF
THIS.
DOES THIS GO AND BACK INTO THE
FUND THE SOMEONE SAID IT MAY
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AT LOW DOES IT OR DOES
IT NOT.
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO CIRCLE
BACK AROUND WITH YOU OKAY.
OKAY I THINK THIS IS INTERESTING
YEAH I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT
WILL HAPPEN AS WE GO ALONG WITH
THE VARIOUS COMMITTEES TO LOOK
AT IT AND. SEE HOW IT ACTUALLY
OPERATES CLEARLY WE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING THAT HELPED OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN DEBT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I WANT
THOSE WHO CAN PAY TO BE
RESPONSIBLE AND PAY YOU KNOW
THOSE KIND OF THINGS SO I LOOK
FORWARD.
SEEING HOW IT ROLLSOUT IN TERMS
OF THE OF THE COMMITTEES SO
THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IS OUR MOTION.
WELL THE BILL.
MOVE BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO ARAMBULA BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
SEVEN THREE YOUR BILL IS UP.
NEXT.
ITEM THREE AND SIX MISTER
CALDERON.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M GONNA BE STARTING.
WITHOUT.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
ITEM THREE.
MAYBE GET ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CURRENTLY CREATES THE FINANCIAL
AID SHOPPING SHE.
ALSO KNOWN JUST AS A SHOPPING
SHEET THAT SCHOOLS CAN VOLUNTARY
LEAH DOT
TO COMMUNICATE FINANCIAL AID TO
STUDENTS.
THE SHOPPING SHEET IS A CONSUMER
TOOL DESIGNED TO NOTIFY STUDENTS
ABOUT A TERMINATION.
ABOUT A UNIVERSITIES GRADUATION
RATES LOAN DEFAULT RATES.
ASKED IT YET THE LOAN DEFAULT
RATES IN MEDIAN STUDENT
BORROWING. UP THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE ALL COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
USE THE SHOPPING SHEET WHEN
COMMUNICATING FINANCIALLY
PACKAGES TO STUDENTS.
WHEN THE INSTITUTE OF FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
EXAMINED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FINANCIAL AID LETTERS. ARE AWARD
LETTERS THAT UNIVERSITIES
CREATED THEY FOUND A SIXTY SIX
PERCENT OF THOSE LETTERS
DECEITFULLY GROUPED ALL THE
SOURCES OF A TOGETHER WITH NO
DISTINCTION FOR WHAT WAS
REQUIRED TO BE PAID BACK. AND
WHAT WAS A GIFT THIS TACTIC
HIGHLIGHTS THE URGENT NEED FOR
STATE INTERVENTION TO ENSURE.
BASIC CONSUMER PROTECTION IS
PROVIDED FOR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL ALSO STIPULATES THAT
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION IS
TASKED WITH IDENTIFYING EX
SUCCESSOR DOCUMENT TO THE
SHOPPING SHEET IF IT IS
DISCONTINUED OR CHANGED. THIS IS
IMPORTANT CASE ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MINT BEGINS
MAINTAINING THIS LETTER IN THE
NAME OF THE LETTER IS CHANGE OR
IF IT IS ENTIRELY DISCONTINUED.
WITHOUT UNIFORM FINANCIALLY
LETTER STUDENTS WASTE TIME
DECODING AND COMPARING
FINANCIALLY PACKAGES THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS AND DATA OR
ARE PURPOSEFULLY DECEITFUL. THIS
IS WHAT THAT LETTER LOOKS LIKE.
ESSENTIALLY JUST A PIECE OF
PAPER WHERE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES FILL IN THE BLANKS
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
FORCE COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES TO
FILL THIS OUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT
THIS BILL DOES REQUIRES THAT
THEY FILL THIS OUT. TO GIVE
STUDENTS A PROPER SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT THEIR FINANCIAL LIABILITIES
GONNA BE. ARE AND YOU KNOW IN
THE EVENT THAT SOMETHING WITHIN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CHANGES
THEY DISCONTINUED THIS LETTER OR
YOU KNOW IT MOVES TO A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT OR THEY CHANGE SOME
ASPECT OF IT. THEN IT IS UPON
THE FINANCIALLY COMMISSION ARE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
DETERMINE THAT SUCCESSOR ALSO
THAT'S REALLY ALL THIS BILL DOES
AND IT'S ALL IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY TO ALLOW
STUDENTS AN IDEA. OF WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO FACE ARE WHEN
IT COMES TO THEIR STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENTS IN THEIR DEBT PAYMENTS
SO THAT THEY. THEY CAN BETTER
ASSESS WHAT THEY'RE WILLING TO
GET THEMSELVES INTO SO THE NOT
PUTTING THEMSELVES IN THE
POSITION THAT THEY CAN'T HANDLE
OUT WHEN THEY GET OUT OF COLLEGE
OR THAT LEASE THAT THEY'RE GOING
INTO. THEIR FINANCIAL OUT MEANS
AND AND WHAT THAT'S GOOD THAT'S
WHAT THEIR EDUCATION IS GOING TO
COST HIM WITH EYES WIDE OPEN
RATHER THAN IT BEING UP
PURPOSEFULLY.
AB MISDIRECTED OR NOT GIVEN ALL
THE INFORMATION.
AND YOU KNOW SO THAT THEY CAN
MAKE A BETTER DECISION OP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN WITH ME. ARE TODAY I HAVE A
MOUSA BARTOS AND BRANDON BY KURT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TO NAY
COMMISSION TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS I
THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THE COMMISSION.
I'M MELISSA BARDO REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSION. THE COMMISSION A
SUPPORTIVE OF INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY AND EARLIER WHERE
DEATH THROUGH UTILIZATION OF THE
FINANCIALLY CHOPPING SHE.
ON COLLEGE COSTS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR FINANCIAL AID. AT THE
COMMISSION IDENTIFIED THAT MANY
CAMPUSES ALREADY USED THE
FINANCIALLY CHOPPING SHE
PRIMARILY TO INFORM BETTER AND
ABOUT THEIR FINANCIAL AID
OPPORTUNITIES. AND WE THINK THAT
THE FINANCIALLY CHOPPING SHE CAN
BE YOU THAT THE COUPLE MET FOR A
BROADER COMMUNICATION EFFORT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COMMISSION WOULD IDENTIFY A
THICK THE THIRD DOCUMENT IN THE
FUTURE.
WE WOULD CERTAINLY WORK CLOBBER
DELUDE LEAVE WHAT AFFECT MET
REPRESENTATIVE THROUGH A BOARD
THAT THE COMMISSION RUNS THE
FINANCIAL AID ADVISORY BOARD.
I'M AND ALSO WITH THE COMMISSION
ITSELF WHICH HAD REPRESENTATIVE
FROM EACH SEGMENT.
I'M I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SYNDICATE STAY ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE HAVE NOT
SENATOR OFFICIAL. ON A SUPPORT
LETTER BUT WE'D LIKE TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CONCEPT.
CHARGER SO TELL SEATS IN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
ANY TWEENER.
OPPOSITION.
TO A PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
.
MISTER JUST MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SCOTT GOVERNOR BEHALF THE
UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX.
WE PROVIDE THE SHEET WE HAVE NO
ISSUE WITH THE INTENT OF THE
MEASURE.
PROBLEM PROBLEM IS HOW THE
MEASURE IS WORDED.
SECTION ONE AND TWO ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE IDENTICAL HOWEVER IF YOU
LOOK AT SECTION ONE LINE EIGHT.
THERE IS NO COMMA AFTER THE WORD
EDUCATION.
SECTION TWO WINE EIGHT THERE IS
A CALM THAT COMIC CHANGES THE
INTENT OF THE LANGUAGE.
SUPPOSED TO BE IDENTICAL WHY ARE
THEY DIFFERENT CAN GO BACK TO
THAT PLEASE SHARE FORCE.
SECTION ONE LINE EIGHT AFTER THE
WORD EDUCATION THERE IS NO COM
ON ON THE FIRST PAGE OR AND I
NAY LOOKIN.
SECOND PAGE.
SECTION.
LINE WHAT.
MY LINE EIGHT AFTER THE WORD
EDUCATION THERE IS NO COM.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
CORRECT.
PAGES DEBRIS LINE EIGHT AFTER
THE WORD EDUCATION THERE IS A
COM.
THAT CHANGES THE INTENT WHAT THE
LANGUAGE SAYS NOW IS THE STUDENT
EIGHT COMMISSION HAS THE
DISCRETION TO CHOOSE A SUCCESSOR
AT THEIR SOLE DISCRETION.
WE HAVE SEE FACT HAS NO
JURISDICTION OVER. MY CLIENTS
WE DON'T TAKE CAL GRANTS WERE
NOT ELIGIBLE.
THEREFORE THIS NOTION AND IT'S
REFERENCED IN THE ANALYSIS OF
GIVING SEE SACKED THE AUTHORITY
TO CHOOSE A DOCUMENT EVEN FROM A
NON GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY THAT'S
WHAT THE ANALYSIS SAYS.
IS.
DISCONCERTING FROM MY CLIENT IF
THE INTENT IS THAT THIS BE FROM
THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ALL WE'RE ASKING IS
THAT YOU PUT IT DOWN.
I ITEM DEVELOPED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WITHOUT
WERE ALL GOOD BUT NOW IT'S
NEBULOUS.
WE DON'T PARTICIPATING THE OF
THE BOARD'S REFERENCE POLICY
SACK SWEEP ACTUALLY HAVE NO
INPUT.
IF THEY SELECTED SOMETHING FROM
TKS OR A NON GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY
AGAIN IF THE INTENT IS THAT. YOU
KNOW THE DOCUMENT WHICH CHANGED
BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION JUST SAY A DOCUMENT
DEVELOP A US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THAT'S ALL WE'RE
ASKING. I AM AND IF I MAY
RESPOND FIRST OF ALL THE COMMON
THINGS IN THERE THAT'S JUST NEW
TO RIGHT NOW AND WITH REGARD TO
THE OTHER PIECE. I AM HAPPY TO
WORK ON ALL THE COMMENTS YOU
WANT BUT WITH REGARDS TO.
YOU KNOW.
THE OTHER PIECE YEAH I MEAN EVEN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS REFLECTS
THAT THE INTENT IS NOT TO HAVE
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
CREATE A NEW SHOPPING SHE BUT
RATHER AUTHORIZED STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO IDENTIFY. A
SUCCESSOR DOCUMENT THAT MAY BE
DEVELOPED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OR ANOTHER ENTITY
ANOTHER SLT SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WHAT THEY COULD GET RID
OF IT ALL ENTIRELY OF THAT
THAT'S IT THAT BUT THAT PUT US
IN A POSITION WHERE NOW WE HAVE
NOTHING FOR STUDENTS. OUGHT TO
GIVE THEM THAT IT UP PROPER
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT THE FUTURE'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE TIMES
FINANCIALLY AND SO I THINK. BY
DEFINITION OR BY REASON YOU HAVE
TO HAVE ANOTHER DOCUMENT OR
ANOTHER ENTITY CREATE SOMETHING
I AND SO I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORK THESE ISSUES WITH
YOU. AYE AGAIN BECOME A THING
THAT'S NEW TO ME HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THAT BOTH REGARDS I MEAN
I THINK IT'S PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AS WELL AS.
MINNOW LOGICALLY AND THEN ALSO
AS A STATE IN THE BILL AS ALSO I
NOTED BY THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THERE.
NOW THERE'S A COMMON ONE SECTION
IN NOT IN THE OTHER BOTH TO BE
IDENTICAL LANGUAGE BY ADEQUATE
COM.
I LIKE.
AND SPEAKING I GOT A LETTER
RIGHT HERE. PER WEEK.
OF COURSE.
SENATE SENTENCE STRUCTURE. IF
YOU LOOK AT SECTION ONE.
IT'S ALL ONE SENTENCE.
SO AGE SHOPPING SHEET AS
DEVELOPED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OR SUCCESSOR.
SECTION TWO.
DEVELOPED BY UNITED STATES PART
OF EDUCATION KARMA OR.
EXACERBATE UNIT.
CREATE TWO INDEPENDENT SENTENCES
THERE IN THERE IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE THE SAME THING BUT IT IS NOT.
YEAH I GUESS IF I HAD IT WORK A
CHAIR I JUST AVOIDED AYE.
AND I WANT UNDERSTAND THE CALM
AND SO YOUR VIEW IS.
WHY DOES THAT NEW STRUCTURE A IN
WHAT WAY IS THAT YOU STRUCTURE
ALTER THE I LIKELY HAVE MEANING
WE BELIEVE THAT IT COULD BE
CONSTRUED IN SECTION TWO THAT
SEE SACK COULD?
SELECT THE DOCUMENT AT THEIR
SOLE DISCRETION WEARS IN SECTION
ONE IT'S INTENDED TO ALL BE A
RUN ON IT'S A DOCUMENT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OR
SUCCESSOR.
YOUR CREW .
BUT AT THE OR SUCCESSOR
DOCUMENTS SO I DON'T SEE HOW
THAT GETS YOU AND YOU'RE
PROBABLY RIGHT. WITH THAT THAT'S
CORRECT WE WOULD PREFER
SPECIFICITY AND IN FACT NOW THAT
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
REYES THAT IF IT SAYS ANOTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY.
IT'S FINE IT'S A NON
GOVERNMENTAL WHERE OUR CONCERN
LIES
I SO TO THE EXTENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OR
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT YOU FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THAT RESOLVES OUR
ISSUE WORK GOT MORE THAN HAPPY
TO AFTER WORK ON THAT ISSUE I
MEAN.
AND HIS OFFICE IS BEEN VERY
RESPOND A AYE AGAIN THAT THAT
HAD NOT BEEN SOMETHING THAT WAS
RAISED BEFORE SPECIFIC TO VOTE
AND TOTALING WAS BECAUSE THE
COMMA BUT WITH REGARDS TO THIS
OTHER ISSUE. I WILL MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK THROUGH THAT ISSUE
MOVING FORWARD.
THEN AND AGAIN I THINK YOU ALL
KNOW ME PRETTY WELL I'M ONE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH ANYBODY FOR
AS LONG AS IT TAKES TO GET. AS
MUCH CONSENSUS AS POSSIBLE
SO LONG AS IT'S A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY DEVELOPING THIS DOCUMENT.
FINE.
IT'S JUST.
YEAH IT HAPPENED ON FLOOR ALL
THE OPTIONS WITH THE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WEBSTER LIVING YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU.
SOBRE CALDERON FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL SICK GOOD BILL GREAT
INTENTION.
.
YOU KNOW I HER HEARD THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS OR I DON'T
ARGUE NEUTRAL WITH OUR
AMENDMENTS LIKE WHAT WHAT
EXACTLY IS YOUR POSITION HOW
WOULD NEUTRALIZE THEM GRACE I
DON'T CALL THEM THE OPPOSITION.
I THINK THEY THEY WANT TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL GETTING TO
WHERE IT IS.
SOUNDS LIKE A BIT OF
MISCOMMUNICATION PROBLEM HAPPENS
ALL THE TIME SO GLAD TO HEAR
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
THEM ON.
WHAT SEEMS TO BE SOME CHANGES
THAT WON'T GO AFTER THE INTENT
OF YOUR BILL THE SPIRIT OF YOUR
BILL?
THAT I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY
WITH THAT TO ADEQUATE.
MR GOT. AND I'LL JUST ADD THAT
TO IT YOU KNOW AYE EMPIRES HAVE
RISEN AND FALLEN ON THAT THAT
PLACEMENT OF COMMAS SO ACTUALLY
THIS IS A. AYE VERY DILIGENT AND
I AND GOOD WORK TO POINT THIS
OUT AND I ALSO AM A VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE FLICK IS A GREAT
EL AL ON THE UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THESE CONCERNS WILL BE
ADDRESSED.
MS BAKER.
I LIKEWISE AS THAT COMIC GEEK I
I APPRECIATE THE POINT OUT AND
THAT YOU'LL BE OPEN HUMBLY TO
HAVE THAT SUGGESTIONS FOR HOW TO
FIX IT BECAUSE WHEN THIS COMES
BACK ON THE FLOOR.
WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL SEE IT WILL
BE FIXED ON BE NICE SAILING.
I WAS AN ENGLISH CLASS AND I.
STUCK WITH ME.
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE NOWI
APPRECIATE THE.
THE COMMENTS IN AGAIN
ABSOLUTELY.
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK FOLLOW AT
MOVE FORWARD IN GOOD FAITH.
AND IT RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE
VOTE DO HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED BY THIS QUIRK SILVA SECOND
BY MISTER LEVINE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEDINA I'VE.
MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM.
BLOOM I SHOP IS CURRENT IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE THE WIEN.
LEVINE I LOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT
AND WILL MOVE TO ITEM SIX.
IF YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OFF
FIRST I WANT TO ACCEPT THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND ONE THINK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK IS
ALSO CHAIR. OF THIS BILL
REQUIRES ARE AB NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE REQUIRES
PARTICIPATING UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES TO CREATE PROCEDURES
FOR INCOME BASED REPAYMENT PLANS
FOR DREAM LOANS.
DREAM LOANS HELP STUDENTS WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND HAVE
FINANCIAL NEED AT UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES AFFORD EDUCATIONALLY
RELATED EXPENSES CURRENTLY
STUDENTS ONLY OPTION TO REPAY
THEIR DREAM LOANS. WITH EQUAL
PAYMENTS OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD
ARE WITH PEOPLE PAYMENTS OVER
TENURE PERIOD. UNDER AN INCOME
BASED REPAYMENT PLAN A STUDENT
LOAN PAYMENT IS BASED ON THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY.
MORE PER PAYMENT FLEXIBILITY IS
IMPORTANT FOR MANY REASONS GIVEN
THE CURRENT POLITICAL LANDSCAPE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND DHAKA HAS
LEAD TO TREPIDATION AMONG THE
STUDENTS ABOUT TAKING OUR
DREAMLAND STUDENTS TAKING OUT
DREAM LOANS ARE NOT CONFIDENT.
THEY HAVE THEY CAN BE LAWFULLY
EMPLOYED IN THE UNITED STATES
HAMPERING THEIR ABILITY TO REPAY
THESE LOANS.
STUDENT WHO WAS UNDOCUMENTED WHO
IS WORRIED ABOUT REPAYING A
DREAM LOAN MAY BE DISSUADED FROM
PURSUING A CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE OR NONPROFIT WORK DO TO
LOW ENTRY LEVEL PAY. LATINO
STUDENTS WHO ARE THE PRIMARY
RECIPIENTS OF DREAM LOANS.
EXPERIENCE HISTORIC WAGE
DISCRIMINATION THIS WAGE
DISPARITY MAKES IT EVEN HARDER
TO REPAY LOANS ON A STANDARD
REPAYMENT PLAN. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL IS ABOUT
EQUALITY BY CREATING AN INCOME
BASED REPAYMENT PLAN FOR DREAM
LOANS ARE PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
COMMUNICATE THAT THE STUDENTS
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AS
THEIR DOCUMENTED PEERS TO
PURSUE.
AN EDUCATION KNOWING THEY CAN
FLEXIBLE THEY CAN HAVE
FLEXIBILITY TO REPAY THEIR LOANS
UPON GRADUATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
AND AND I WILL SAY.
THAT YOU KNOW WITH WITH.
WITH THE FACT THAT WE DO HAVE
DISABILITY IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
STUDENTS TO ACCEPT THESE LOANS.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE IS
UNCERTAINTY RIGHT NOW WITH THAT
WITH WITH THE PROGRAM. ARE
INCOME BASED REPAYMENT PROGRAM
IS WHAT'S FAIR AND IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO OUR TO PUT INTO
LAW CODIFIED INTO LAW OUR
STUDENTS WHO ARE DOCUMENTED THAT
HAVE STUDENT LOANS.
THEY CAN APPLY AND GET A A.
UP INCOME BASED PAYMENT PROGRAM
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ISN'T
NEW THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT
SOMEBODY WHO IS YOU KNOW A
DOCUMENT STUDENT DOESN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO AS WELL THROUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THEY CAN
PUBLIC IMPLYING GET THE SAME
STATUS. SO I THINK IT'S ONLY
FAIR ARE YOU KNOW THAT WE CAN
CREATE THE SAME STANDARDS FOR
THE STUDENTS OUR DREAM ONCE
AGAIN MANY OF WHOM. NO NO OTHER
HOME OTHER THAN THIS COUNTRY
OTHER THAN CALIFORNIA I HAVE A
FRIEND. SIX MONTHS OLD BROUGHT
HERE KNOWS NO OTHER HOME. TOLD
GO BACK TO MEXICO HE SAYS WHERE
I'VE NEVER LIVED ANYWHERE ELSE
SO I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT WE IMPLEMENT SOME LIKE
THIS IT'S REALLY SMALL BUT IT
GOES A LONG WAY TO MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN ITS IN ITS FAIR.
AYE AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
GOOD NEWS IN A TIME WHEN THERE'S
SO MUCH UNCERTAINTY WE STUDENTS
ARE CONSTANTLY GETTING BAD NEWS.
THINKING RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY
AND SUPPORT IS JUST YOU RYAN WHO
IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JESSE RYAN
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
WE ARE A BROAD BASED BIPARTISAN
COALITION OF BUSINESS CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS AND EDUCATION
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE. SOLELY
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE MORE STUDENTS GETTING INTO
AND SUCCEEDING IN COLLEGE.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA IS A
STATE THAT IS PROUDLY BUILT BY
IMMIGRANTS WERE ALSO HOME TO
MORE THAN TWO MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND AN
ESTIMATED EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
CURRENTLY UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
ARE IN ELIGIBLE FOR ANY FORM OF
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID NOT ONLY
GRANTS BUT ALSO WORK STUDY IN
STUDENT LOANS.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS HAVE
LACKED THE ABILITY TO BORROW
FUNDS ON THE SAME TERMS AS THEIR
PEERS WHO CAN ACCESS MORE
AFFORDABLE REPAYMENT OR EVEN
LOAN FORGIVENESS OPTIONS?
THROUGH AB FIVE FORTY IN THE
DREAM ACT CALIFORNIA HAS ALLOWED
MANY UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO
QUALIFY FOR IN STATE TUITION
RATES AND MOST STATE FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS EXCLUDING THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS.
WITH SENATOR LAURA'S LEADERSHIP
WE SAW THAT CALIFORNIA ALSO
ESTABLISHED THE DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM TO PAIR STATE AND
INSTITUTIONAL DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AT THE CSU
YOU SEE. WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCESS STUDENT LOANS ON
REASONABLE TERMS.
FOLLOWING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ELECTION UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
GREW WORRIED ABOUT THEIR ABILITY
TO CONTINUE TO BE EDUCATED.
BECAUSE OF THEIR FAMILY STATUS
AND WORRIED ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN ABILITY TO
AFFORD COLLEGE.
THE CAMPAIGN HAS HEARD FROM MANY
OF THE STUDENTS AND OUR PARTNERS
SERVING THE STUDENTS ON CAMPUSES
THAT THEY ARE INCREASINGLY
WORRIED ABOUT INCURRING DEBT TO
COVER COLLEGE EXPENSES. AND
THEY'RE UNSURE OF THEIR
ABILITIES SECURE GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT IN THE U. S. AFTER
GRADUATING.
INCOME BASED REPAYMENT WHICH WE
HEARD A ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
SPEAK SO ELOQUENTLY OF IS
SOMETHING THAT I AM A
BENEFICIARY OF THE SOMETHING
THAT MY HUSBAND IS CURRENTLY
TAKING ADVANTAGE UP WITHOUT THAT
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE WOULD STAY
AFLOAT. WE KNOW THAT ALL
STUDENTS DESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE PREDICTABLE AFFORDABLE
MEANS OF PAIN BACK
WITHOUT DEFAULTING ON LOANS AND
WITHOUT INCURRING HIGHER
PAYMENTS EVERY MONTH.
FURTHERMORE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO HAVE WORK JUST AS
HARD TO EARN A SPOT AT THE CSU
IN UC SHOULD NOT NEED TO DROP
OUT DUE TO COST.
THE STUDENTS ARE FACING
CHALLENGES THAT MANY OF US FIND
IT DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE.
FORTUNATELY WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES WE
ARE WELL POSITIONED TO SUPPORT
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE.
THE ABILITY TO PAY FOR COLLEGE
SHOULD NEVER OUT WAY NEVER OUT
WAY
STUDENTS ABILITY.
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL STUDENTS TO
HAVE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
ALL STUDENTS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
DREAM LOANS IN INCOME BASED
REPAYMENT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JERRY SO CAL STATES IN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MANY RODRIGUEZ FROM THE
EDUCATION TRUST LAST YEAR IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I ALEX GREAT CSU WHERE WE'RE
GONNA TWEENER WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION AND I WE'VE BEEN
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE.
LEGISLATION THAT WE THE CREATED
THIS PROGRAM AYE WE'VE ENGAGED
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE STAFF
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO OUR
INTEREST IS JUST ENSURING THAT.
ARE THE STUDENTS HAVE THE.
ASSURANCE IS THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GO INTO.
.
THERE ARE GOING TO DEFAULT ON
THEIR LOAN SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AYE WE
ALSO JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THIS PROGRAM REMAINS SELF
SUSTAINABLE AFTER A CAMPUSES IN
THE FUTURE SO WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I CHAIR MEMBERS TYLER I DO ARE
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
LIKE THIS YES YOU WE ALSO
SUPPORT AND THE DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM.
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF THE BILL
AND WE SHARED SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AROUND COSTS WITH THE
STAFF AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE MEANS A
RESPONSIVE. AND I CONTINUE TO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
I'D SAY NO OTHER TWEETERS ANY
ONE IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DO HAVE A MOTION.
MOVE BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY.
YOUR LEVINE.
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD. CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO THE.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING LEVINE. LEVINE
AYE LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
NINE ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT.
NEXT.
ITEM NINE MISTER LACKING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THEIR SIDE ACR.
IT SURE WOULD FORTY FIVE
EXPRESSES THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO LUMP THE
CALIPHATE IT'S HARD TO LAUNCH.
THE CALIFORNIANS JUDE FOR
AEROSPACE IN THE ADULT VALLEY
WHICH WE LIKE TO CALL. AEROSPACE
VALLEY.
ESTABLISHED A TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA'S TO TO TO BEEN
TREMENDOUS RESOURCES FOR
RESEARCH.
AND ALL SORTS OF INDUSTRIES.
THEY'VE SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESS
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING THE GLOBE
IN FIELDS OF BIOLOGY.
PHYSICS.
CHEMISTRY ECONOMICS AND
MEDICINE.
THIS ISN'T TO WHICH STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION AS A
GLOBAL LEADER IN THE AEROSPACE
AND INDUSTRY.
INCREASED PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
AT SERVICE THE FINAL BETWEEN
UNIVERSITIES AND THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY.
CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESS IN
AEROSPACE RESEARCH.
DEVELOPMENT AND PRODUCTION IS
NOT ONLY ENVIED BY OTHER STATES
BUT HIGHLY COVETED.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY COMPANIES AND PROGRAMS
LEARN AWAY.
TO HELP THE INDUSTRY A TRACTOR
RETRAIN THE TALENT IT NEEDS TO
PROPEL IT FORWARD. CALIFORNIA
SHOULD CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER WHO'S.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MOTION BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND
BY.
BAKER MADAM SECRETARY OF THE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOOD THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
CHAIR MEMBERS.
TEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR.
ADD ONS.
AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO.
I.
FIVE. DOCTOR WEBER
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT YOU
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR. A
BILL RELATING TO STOOP STUDENT
FOOD INSECURITY IN COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
UP MOST OF YOU'VE HEARD THE DATA
BEFORE IN TERMS OF HOW OF THE
VARIOUS STUDIES HAVE INDICATED
THAT OUR SCHOOLS OF.
BASICALLY OF MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE HUNGRY HELD A LACK
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE BALANCED
MEALS. AND IT VARIES WITH THE
VARIOUS INSTITUTIONS WHERE.
SEE ISSUE WAS ABOUT FORTY ONE
PERCENT OF AND THESE.
AND WITH THAT AS WELL AS TEN
PERCENT OF THE C. ISSUE STUDENTS
ARE HOMELESS. OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT IN TERMS OF STUDENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO ADEQUATE
FOOD. OF RECENT SURVEY AT THE
WILL OF THE WISCONSIN HOPE LEFT
FOUND THAT OVER HALF OF THE FOUR
THOUSAND RECIPIENTS.
I RESPONDED TO EXCUSE ME AT THE
TEN COMMITTEE CLOUDS ACROSS
NATION FACED FROM SOME FORM OF
STUDENTS. FOOD INSECURITY UP
MAYBE AWARE OF A PREVIOUS BILLS
WE PASS IN THIS HOUSE AND EVEN
LESS YOU SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN.
I WAS SIGNED INTO LAW THAT
REQUIRES UNIVERSE IN BECAUSE THE
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR COUNTIES
CAL FURNITURE REGISTRARTE
PROGRAM.
IT'S INTERESTING AS WE CONTINUE
TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF.
UP FOOD INSECURITY THAT EVERY
TIME WE THINK WE'VE A SOLVE THE
PROBLEM IN THE LOAN CROPS UP
THAT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT WE COME BACK AND DO
ADDITIONAL WORK. WE'VE DONE
THREE BILL SO FAR THAT HAVE
BASICALLY DEALT WITH THE ISSUE
OF FOOD INSECURITY THAT BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW. A EIGHTEEN THIS
BILL EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR WILL
FURTHER IMPROVE ACCESS TO
FEDERAL ANTI HUNGER BENEFITS.
CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOMES COLLEGE
STUDENTS BY ONE EXPANDING THE
CAL FRENCH RESTAURANT MEALS
PROGRAM TO ALLOW ALL SEE ISSUE
LOCATIONS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
OR NOT. THERE COUNTY HAS CHOSEN
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
FOR THE NON STUDENT POPULATION.
CURRENTLY ONLY NINE COUNTIES
PARTICIPATE IN THEM A RESTAURANT
OF MEAL PROGRAM LEAVING OUT TNC
ISSUES THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM SO WHAT THIS DOES
BASICALLY IS THAT EMPOWERS THE
STUDENT WHO. ARE WHO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR CAO FRESH UP MAYBE COMING
FROM AN AREA WHERE THEY HAVE
CALPERS PROGRAMS I ALL OF A
SUDDEN TO ARRIVE AT A CAMPUS
THAT DOESN'T HAVE ONE IN THEIR
COUNTY. AND IT GIVES THE CAMPUS
IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
TO ALLOW THE STUDENTS TO USE
THEIR CAL FRESH ON MY CAMPUS FOR
THEIR RESTAURANT MEALS PROGRAM.
UP TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR IS JENNIFER
MCGUIRE WHOSE ASSIST A PROFESSOR
OF SOCIAL WORK AT HUMBOLDT
STATE.
AND ELLEN VAULT VOLUNTARY WHO'S
THE LEGAL DIRECTOR FOR FOOD
RESEARCH AND ACTION CENTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANKS FOR
INVITING ME HERE TO SPEAK UPON
ABOUT THIS RESEARCH.
SO I M. THOUGH CO. PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR FOR THE CSU BASIC
NEEDS
STUDY THAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU RIGHT NOW. AND THAT MY RIGHT
I DO.
EXCUSE ME MICHAEL REESE
RESEARCHERS AFTER SHE TO
CRUTCHFIELD WHO IS FROM LONG
BEACH STATE. AND SO DOCTOR WEBER
THANK YOU FOR TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THAT THE PREVALENCE THAT WE
SEE IN FOOD INSECURE OR FOR
PUTTING SECURING HOMELESS
STUDENTS. AND I JUST WANNA TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE IMPACTS THAT
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING. ON IN
REGARDS TO ACADEMICS THOSE
STUDENTS WHO WERE FOOD IN
SECURING HOMELESS WERE THEIR
GPAS WERE LOWER THEIR ACADEMIC
CONCERNS WERE HIGHER. AND IN
REGARDS TO THEIR MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH
IBM REPORTED MORE DAYS WHERE
THEY WERE EXPERIENCING AND
NEGATIVE IMPACTS FOR THOSE. AND
WHEN WE LOOK THAT STUDENTS WHO
WERE VERY LOW FOOD SECURE SO
THESE ARE THE STUDENTS WHO WERE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING HUNGER. AND
ALSO.
WITH THAT HUNGER ARE ALSO
EXPERIENCING
I. THINK THEM THAT GO ALONG WITH
IT SUCH AS FEELING WEAK HAVING
TROUBLE CONCENTRATING. AND
HAVING TROUBLE SHOWING UP TO
SCHOOL WE SAW THAT THERE LOW
FOOD IN SECURING HOMELESS
STUDENTS MISSED DOUBLE THE DAYS
ARM. OF SCHOOL OR WORK OR
SHOWING UP TO THE RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITIES AS THEIR FOOD AND
HOUSING SECURE COUNTERPARTS.
AND SO WE KNOW WE HAVE A HOST OF
AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE EMERGING
ON CAMPUSES TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
WE KNOW THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
SOLVE FOR THESE ISSUES FOR
HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS.
BUT THE RESTAURANT MEALS
PROGRAM WILL HELP PUT FOOD INTO
THE HANDS OF STUDENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY. TO STORE
OR PREPARE THEIR FOOD BECAUSE
THEY'RE HOMELESS AND SO I THINK
THIS IS A. REALLY GOOD BILL AND
I COMMEND DOCTOR WEBER FOR
WRITING IN THE COMMITTEE
HOPEFULLY FOR SUPPORTING IT.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT ABILITY
VOLUNTEER WITH THE FOOD RESEARCH
AND ACTION CENTER NATIONAL AYE
DONE URBANIZATION. BASED IN DC
AND WE ARE HONORED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
FOUR WE KNOW OF THE VERY
TREMENDOUS STRIDES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HERE IS MADE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MADE. ON COLLEGE
HUNGER AND DO SEE THIS UP AS AN
ADDITIONAL STEP THAT WILL
STRENGTHEN THE OPPORTUNITY
PARTICULARLY FOR HOMELESS
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO HAVE THE
ACCESS AND REALLY APPLAUD AT THE
FACT THAT DOES SEE IF YOU WOULD
WANT TO STAND UP AND DO THIS SO.
A WEEK LEARJET I.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SYNDICATE STILL BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CAMINO COLLEGES AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF ON OUR HOUSE AND I'M HAVE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
TRUCKS FOR
.
GARCIA BUT AS WITH THE WESTERN
SURINAME POVERTY SPONSORED
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CHARGER SO CAL STATE
SINICIZATION INTRON SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THAT AFTERNOON ALEX GRAVES
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY WE
SUPPORTED AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN LAST YEAR PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AGAIN. ARE THIS BILL
THIS YEAR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MANY RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE EDUCATION TRUST WES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I HAD OTHER I'M REPRESENTING
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY TWO WINNERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE.
COMMITTING DOCTOR RUMBLED.
YEAH I JUST.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A PROBLEM WE
HAVE AT PRESENT STATE AS WELL
AND I WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT IT IF
I COULD DO OUR FIRST LADY MARY
CASTRO WHO REALLY HAS WORKED.
DILIGENTLY TO OPEN UP A FOOD
PANTRY BUT BECAUSE OF THE HEAT
ON OUR CAMPUS WE'VE SERVED FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
FIFTY THOUSAND MEALS.
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
AND SO I DID SEE ONE YOUR
RECOMMENDATION TO CLONE MISS
CASTRO BUT THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING YOU GUYS CONSIDER.
YOU KNOW SHE SHE DID HAVE A NAP
THAT WHAT WHEN THEY'RE CLOSING
UP AN EVENT AT FRESNO STATE THEY
THEN NOTIFY STUDENTS AS WELL SO
THAT THEY CAN COME AND EAT
BEFORE. THEY CLOSE THAT EVENT
THAT MAY BE SOMETHING FURTHER
DOWN THE LINE YOU MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER TO INCORPORATE A
SEVERAL OF THE CAMPUSES HAVE
THAT NOW THERE WAS A FOODS OF
STUDENT NEED FOOD INSECURITY
CON.
CONFERENCE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THAT I SPOKE AT ABOUT A MONTH
AGO. AND THAT THAT AT WAS
BROUGHT OUT IT AND SEVERAL OF
THE CAMPUSES NOW HAVE THESE APPS
BECAUSE THEY. KNOW CAMPUS HAS A
PARTY THE PRESIDENT HAS A PARTY
IS CHICKEN WINGS MEATBALLS AND
WHATEVER PEOPLE CAN'T EVEN WALK
AWAY. AND NOW THEY PUT IT PUT ON
AT THAT THE RECEPTION IS OPEN
YOU COME GET THE FOOD.
AND SO THE STUDENTS COME AND
EAT GET THE FOCUS LEFT OVER SO
THEY HAVE THAT NOW AT SEVERAL
CAMPUSES. ARE AS WELL AS SOME
DORMS ON SOME CAMPUS I'M REALLY
PROUD OF WHAT THE STUDENTS HAVE
DONE. OF THEY HAVE OF THE FARGO
SOMEHOW HUMANITY THAN WE HAVE
BECAUSE OF THEY JUST OPEN IT UP
TO THOSE IN NEED AND THEY WORK
SO HARD FOR THEIR PANTRIES. UP
BUT THEY ALSO AT THE IF IT'S ACT
STATE AND SOME OF THE CAMPUS
HAVE SET ASIDE TEN ROOMS IN THE
DORMS.
THE KIDS WERE HOMELESS
AND THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STAY THERE FOR THIRTY DAYS.
TO GET THEMSELVES OF ORGANIZED
TO FIND A PLACE TO STAY AND GET
THE NECESSARY GOVERNMENTAL
SUPPORT SO THEY HAVE THE AT SAKS
THE BAY OF TEN ROOM TO SOME OF
THE OTHER CAMPUSES HAVE
IDENTIFIED DORM ROOMS. THAT THEY
WILL LOVE LET THE STUDENTS STAY
IN FOR THIRTY DAYS WHILE THEY'RE
AT SO THEY WILL NOT BE ON THE
STREETS. AND DOT AND AND SO IT'S
REALLY BEEN AMAZING TO SEE HOW
THE STUDENTS HAVE TAKEN THIS.
AND PUT A TREMENDOUS NEED IS ON
OUR CAMPUSES THAT PLACES THAT WE
DIDN'T THINK WOULD HAVE AS MUCH
UP FOOD INSECURITY HOMELESSNESS
THAT'S THERE. BUT A LOT OF IT IS
COMING FROM A STUDENTS AND I'M
SURE IT FRESNO WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
FRESNO AND. AND SO MANY OTHER
CAMPUSES IN TERMS OF THE
WONDERFUL THINGS ARE DOING
ON-BEHALF OF THEMSELVES OF THEIR
AND THEIR PEERS.
IF THERE ARE NO OTHER COMMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK DOCTOR WEBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
WOULD DOCTOR RUMBULA WHERE AT
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE. AND WE
HEARD FROM STUDENT AFTER STUDENT
WHO ABOUT.
FOOD INSECURITY THERE'S A STORY
I BELIEVE IN TODAY'S LA TIMES.
OF A YOUNG LATINO STUDENT AT CAL
IT UC BERKELEY.
WHO IS ATTENDING CLASSES BUT?
LIVING IN A TRAILER.
WITHOUT.
ELECTRICITY.
AND THEN FACING CHALLENGES SO.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
THE ORIGIN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
SO THE MOTION WAS BY.
DOCTOR RUMBULA SECOND BY MISTER
SANTIAGO. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
SECRETARIAT CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHVEZ IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER AYE.
WEBER I.
WELL ZERO YOUR
BILL IS OUT.
WE WILL GO TO ITEM SEVEN.
YOUR LOVE
.
LET ME LOUDEST THAN THAT.
MAY BEGIN TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD.
I THINK UBER THAT'S THAT IF
ACCOMMODATION.
THIS IS A RETROSPECTIVE AB
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE COORDINATING
ENTITY FOR THE OFFICE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION PERFORMANCE AS YOU
KNOW. HOW WE ARE ONLY ONE OF TWO
STATES THAT DOES NOT HAVE
ACCORDINGLY ENTITY WITH RESPECT
HIGHER EDUCATION AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE?
CONVERSATIONS OCCURRING SO THAT
WE CAN BEST PLAN ACCORDINGLY
WITH THE VARIOUS SEGMENTS AND
SO.
WITH RESPECT TO ASK HER AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME IN SUPPORT IT
WITH CALIFORNIA COMPETES IS
MONDAY A HUSSY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME OF
LAWNDALE JESS AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMPETES.
WHEN INDEPENDENT NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT AIMED AT BOLSTERING
THE STATE'S POST SECONDARY
OUTCOMES.
TO FOSTER A ROBUST ECONOMY
VIBRANT COMMUNITIES AND ENGAGED
CITIZENRY.
I'M HERE AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF MR
LOS BILL AB NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
TO ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION PERFORMANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. CALIFORNIA
COMPETES OF LONG SUPPORTED
GREATER OVERSIGHT IN
COORDINATION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
BUT ONCE HE PACKWOOD'S DEFUNDED
AND EFFECTIVELY DISSOLVED IN
TWENTY ELEVEN IT OCCURRED AT THE
TIME OF HIGHLY TUMULTUOUS TIME
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS THEY FACE BUDGET%
CUTS TECHNOLOGY WAS BEGINNING TO
CHANGE EDUCATIONAL DELIVERY. AND
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WERE AND
QUITE FRANKLY STILL ARE TODAY
QUESTIONING WHETHER OR NOT A
COLLEGE DEGREE. IS WORTH THE
COST.
THESE CHALLENGES HAVE NOT GONE
AWAY IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS AND
THEY'VE ONLY INTESA INTENSIFIED
WITH NEW QUESTIONS ABOUT. LABOR
MARKET SHIPS AND SOARING COSTS
OF LIVING.
DECADES AGO THE STATE MADE A
PROMISE THAT CITIZENS TO
CITIZENS AT A PUBLIC EDUCATION
WOULD BE WAITING FOR EVERY HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE LOOKING FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY.
EVERY SINGLE ONE.
AND IN THE YEARS THAT HAVE
PASSED THIS PACT HAVE STARTED TO
STE
PROCTER.
NOW MORE THAN ANY TIME IN SINCE
THE MASTER PLAN WAS ESTABLISHED
THE STATE NEEDS EXPERT
LEADERSHIP TO UNDERTAKE THE TASK
OF SHEPHERDING ITS HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM BACK. TOWARDS
THE MID ORIGINAL MANDATE OF
PROVIDING EQUITABLE COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS TO ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS.
STRONG POLICY MAKING CRITICAL
OVERSIGHT FOR TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS. UMP
REQUIRES AN INDEPENDENT
MECHANISM TO GUIDE THE PUBLIC
AGENDA.
THERE ARE FOUR PRIMARY
OBJECTIVES THAT WE SEE AS BEING
CRITICAL FOR THIS.
SECULAR AGENCY ONE IS PROJECTING
THE STATE'S HIGHER EDUCATION
NEEDS
SECONDLY IS TO AND IDENTIFY GAPS
BETWEEN WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING OFFERED. AND
WHAT WOULD BEST SERVE THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
INCLUDING THE ADULT STUDENTS IN
THE STATE.
THIRD IS TO DEVELOP COST
EFFECTIVE PROPOSALS FOR
IMPROVING POST SECONDARY
OUTCOMES WHILE BALANCING THE
IMPERATIVES OF ACCESS AND
QUALITY PER OP FOR STUDENTS.
AND THEN FOURTH TO ENHANCE
PLANNING AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COORDINATION FOR IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE SEGMENTS AND WITH
POLICY MAKERS.
UP CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW BECAME AN
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE THANKS IN
LARGE PART TO THE INGENUITY OF
STATE LEADERS WHO RECOGNIZE THAT
INVESTMENT IN OUR RESIDENTS
WOULD RETURN ENORMOUS BENEFITS
TO THE STATE.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO PRIORITIZE HIGH STANDARDS
A STUDENT SUCCESS ACCOUNTABILITY
AND EQUITABLE OUTCOMES WE MUST
HAVE COORDINATION AND HAVE THAT
BE IN THE FOREFRONT OF THE
CONVERSATION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HEART SURGERY SO BECAUSE IT'S AN
ASSOCIATION WHILE WE DON'T OF A
POSITION ON THE BILL CURRENTLY
WE SUPPORT THE IDEA AND CONCEPT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO TAKING A
POSITION ON THE BILL.
MANY RODRIGUEZ FROM THE
EDUCATION TRUST WAS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE.
ANY TWEENER.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AS MAKE.
THANK YOU HAVE MR LOW FOR
BRINGING THIS I THINK THIS WILL
BE THE FOURTH TIME I VOTED FOR
THIS MEASURE WHICH LEADS ME TO
MY QUESTION AND IT'S JUST FOR
FUN.
THE FIRST TIME WHEN IT WAS
CARRIED BY SENATOR LIEU. IT WAS
VETOED ANY THOUGHTS ON
HOW THIS MIGHT'VE BEEN TWO WEEKS
SO IT MIGHT GET PASSED TO VETO
OR.
I YOU MAY RECALL THAT THIS.
GET HELD UP IN APPROPRIATIONS
THE LAST TWO YEARS YES YOUR
VERSION YES.
SO WE ARE CONTINUALLY HAVING
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS.
THAT'S A CONTINUE TO MOVE IT
FOURTH AND TO LAY THE GROUNDWORK
FOR THE CONTINUED SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM PASSED.
OUR TEN YEARS HERE YEAH AND THE
THEN THEN THE HOPES THAT THE
GOVERNOR WILL SIGN IT SINCE HAVE
BEFORE YOU GOT TO CARRY THIS ONE
SENATOR LEWIS CARRIED AND IT WAS
GONNA BE TED SO I HOPE THAT.
IS SUCCESSFUL AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS AYE I WOULD
JOIN MS BAKER AND THANKING ME
OUT THERE FOR BRINGING THIS.
FORWARD AND FOR HIS TENACITY.
AND.
AND KNOW THAT AT OUR.
AT SOME POINT WE WILL HAVE
SOMETHING.
A TWO OVER.
THAT OVER THE CAN.
LOOK AT HIGHER EDUCATION AND A
HOLISTIC A HUESO I KNOW THAT AT
SOME POINT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW.
A WOULD YOU.
LIKE TO CLOSE YES MISTER I ALSO
WANT TO.
.
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT WHEN WE
HAD OUR INTERIM SESSIONS.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION THE SECOND
OF THE HIJACKERS MASTER PLAN
OCCURRED AT MANY DIFFERENT AREAS
AND.
MISTER YOU ARE PRESENT AS WAS
ASSEMBLY WHEN EGGMAN AND
CONTINUALLY PROD UP IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HIRED BECAUSE
MASTER PLAN WAS THE REFERENCE ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE NEED OF A
SUCH A CORNY ENTITY.
IT'S THEN WOULD GIVE ME A SEGUE
INTO.
QUATRE SEGMENT IF YOU IT MIGHT
JUST I WON'T LATE LIKE I WON'T
TAKE UP TOO MUCH MORE TIME JUST
HERE TO ALSO SEEMED TO THE SAME
PART OF THIS DISC THIS COURSE IN
THIS CHOIR. THAT WE NEEDED OVER
ARCHING.
A COORDINATING GROUP FOR THIS
WE HAVE WORKFORCE ISSUES COMING
AND WE HAVE THE TRANSITION OF
OUR WORKFORCE HAPPENING AND I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A REAL
COMPREHENSIVE WAY OF LOOKING AT
THIS. MOMENT WITH THE CHANCELLOR
RECENTLY SOME OF US AND HE
TALKED ABOUT THE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM BEING. LIKE
THAT THAT THE OF THE FEEDER THE.
THE KEY THROUGH TWELVE IN THAT
COMMITTEE COLLEGES BEING THE ON
RAMPS ONTO THE FREEWAY BUT THAT
THE FREEWAYS SO BACKED UP NOBODY
CAN ACTUALLY MERGE.
SO WE'RE PREPARING ALLOW
STUDENTS TO GO A AND WE KNOW WE
HAVE A HUGE CAPACITY ISSUE. WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S DIFFERENT
REGIONS IN THE STATE THAT ARE
GROWING FASTER THAN OTHERS THAT
HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF EQUITY
THAN OTHERS. A AND SO I JUST
THINK AN OVERALL COORDINATING
BODY IS IS PUBLIC WHERE WE NEED
TO.
TO MOVE TOWARDS AND OF COURSE MR
LOW AND I HOPE WE MOVED THERE.
TOWARDS AT FASTER THAN.
SOONER THAN LATER.
THANK YOU.
WE MOTION BY.
MISTER SANTIAGO SECOND BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY REPUBLIC.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHVEZ IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
TWELVE ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT.
NEXT WE HAVE FIVE MISTER CHAIR
MEDINA'S BILL AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN
OR YOURS MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
THE COMMAND CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS.
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
OF THE COUNTRY'S DEFERRED ACTION
FOR CHILDHOOD ARRIVALS OR DACA.
RECIPIENTS LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
ARE ESTIMATED TO BE ENROLLED AT
YOU SEE CSU. AND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS MINORS AND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FROM
SERVING. ON STUDENT BOARDS OR
COMMISSIONS.
WITH UPDATING THE STANDARD
STATEWIDE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
GIVE ALL STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
STUDENT BOARDS.
AND AVOID DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON AGE AND CITIZENSHIP STATUS.
A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WOULD AUTHORIZE ANY PUPIL
ATTENDING THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY SCHOOL.
WHO IS UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN?
SERVE ON CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION BOARDS OR COMMISSIONS.
A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WOULD ALSO ALLOW ANY STUDENT
WITHOUT LAWFUL.
IMMIGRATION STATUS TO SERVE IN
ANY CAPACITY
STUDENT GOVERNMENT AT A
CALIFORNIA POST SECONDARY
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CHARACTERS SO COSTLY THIN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
SIMPLY TO STAY ON BEHALF A
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND SUPPORT.
ERICA REMAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THANK YOU FROM
ENDING TO INCLUDE OUR STUDENTS
IN SUPPORT.
ANGIE MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IT'S MORE.
THIS NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY TWEENER SWITCHES ARE NEW
OFFICIAL CATEGORY HAVE A
COMMITTEE TODAY.
AND ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TURN OVER TO OUR COLLEAGUES
COMMITTEE.
OKAY THEIR IS WHICH CARE CLOSE
YOUR GOOD BUCKLEY US REWRITE
BOTH GREAT THERE IS A MOTION
FROM.
MISTER ARAMBULA. AND A SECOND
FOR MISTER SANTIAGO THIS IS A A
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA I MEDINA AYE BAKER AYE
AYE BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW. LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
THIRTEEN ZERO WITHOUT.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO A BILLS ON
CALL.
WE'RE GOING FILE ORDER SO ITEM
ONE A. B. SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE SCHABAS.
SHUDDERS NOT BOATING.
LOW.
LOW AYE.
THE VOTE WAS NINE THREE.
ITEM ONE.
ITEM TWO A. B. EIGHTEEN OH
THREE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
SHAHBAZ AYE LOW.
LOW AYE.
ITEM THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT.
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE SHOT IS.
SCHABAS AYE LOW.
LOW AYE.
RE A.
ZERO.
ITEM FIVE A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY
FOUR.
CHAVEZ.
SCHABAS I.
ITEM FIVE VOTERS THIRTEEN ZERO
A. B. EIGHT
IN NINETY FOUR.
ITEM SIX A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY
FIVE.
CHAVEZ
SCHABAS AYE LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING.
ITEM SIX ELEVEN ZERO.
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE.
ITEM SEVEN AB NINETEEN TIRTY
SIX
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ NOT VOTING.
ITEM SEVEN THE VOTERS TWELVE
ZERO A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA NOT VOTING.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I.
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I.
LOW.
NOT VOTING.
NOT VOTING TO I
.
ITEM EIGHT.
VOTER SEVEN TWO.
ITEM NINE ACR ONE FOUR FIVE.
CHAVEZ
.
A.
CORRECT.
ITEM EIGHT THE VOTE WAS EIGHT
TO.
AND A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY ONE IS
OUT.
ITEM NINE ACR ONE FOUR FIVE.
CHAVEZ.
SHAHBAZ AYE LOW.
LOW AYE. PATTERSON
PATTERSON I.
ITEM NINE THE VOTERS THIRTEEN
ZERO ACR FOURTEEN FIVE IS OUT.
ITEM TEN ACR ONE FIVE ZERO
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE SHOT IS.
SCHABAS AYE LOW.
LOW AYE.
TEN.
THE VOTERS THERE
ZERO.
YOU ARE ONE
ZERO IS.
WITH THAT WE ARE JOURNAL